the Supreme Court has unceremoniously
rejected the Texas lawsuit supported by
20 other states against four states that
would effectively have overturned the
election that's the news for the night
thanks for tuning in everybody now let's
talk about aliens Alex Jones is joining
me and Michael malice's I'm kidding we
will talk about this go to stuff but yes
Alex Jones is here Michael malice has
returned they've both returned with a
Vengeance because the last podcast we
did got removed and I said as soon as I
it got removed I was like I hit both I
reached out to Alex and and Michael said
can you come back on immediately and
this is the soonest we were able to make
it work so you want to be on a few days
later I'm like absolutely but I gotta
leave town because I didn't have
babysitters but here we are and it's I
had a lot of fun that was amazing last
time and I don't have a toothache today
so I am a little bit better than last
time so thanks for having me yeah right
on and uh and Michael of course hanging
out thanks for having me yes so uh
what's up gorilla murder yourselves what
is that what is that from it's a meme
they made of us that video oh they did
it was really funny there's also a
picture of you going like this with like
the tinfoil hat
oh my gosh uh so earlier I think Luke
posted this photo we had Alex stand in
front of the green screen for a few
minutes just saying whatever so we have
I'm gonna do it again later because I
didn't get what you were saying I
thought I had to do something because
I'm too dense you're like later no no we
got some good stuff it's you doing
different poses then I got it so I was a
little bit denser but let's go back to
this Andreas who's chilling over he
wants to make videos of like music
videos of you dancing and stuff can I
ask you one question because you do the
live streams I'm kicked off YouTube for
a few years so I get to live vicariously
through you I watch all the time I knew
rodowski was here I'm watching them all
week at your house but I'm sitting there
trying to figure this out it had 900 000
and something views that night the next
day it was still 900 000 views then it
goes to like one million three thousand
and then goes away so how does that work
when you obviously we had three or four
million we actually had a total of like
2.3 million is that right yeah yeah 2.3
million so uh I feel like Newsmax but
the but the Newsmax wishes they had that
their top show is at 200 000. I'm not
knocking them that's what I'm saying you
guys are like oh YouTube Don't ban us we
worship you the goddamn show's got
millions of viewers Decker Carlson
that's why they say they got us eating
out of their hand when we bring the
whole game to them I don't think they
care I think I think they want to be
Netflix they want they want you know
they want us to see a lot of
respectability yeah yeah and listen
listen when they just issued this
YouTube it made this ruling where they
said you can't make claims about Trump
and fraud or whatever the report they
put out was actually about their
advertisers it wasn't they didn't care
about fraud or anything they're just
like look advertisers we're doing really
nice for you please don't pull your ads
off our platform no I agree so we got a
discussion before we went live which I
don't even want to go into because I
want to move on from the election to
cover other stuff because I'm Typecast
to always only cover the current
political stuff I'd rather cover the big
classic conspiracy stuff we're gonna do
that tonight but aliens this is process
Texas filed a suit saying that the
legislatures of these other five states
did not pass a law to take mail-in
ballots and so was mute well the Supreme
Court just threw it out big defeat of
trump we should be able to look at that
give our opinion doesn't mean we're the
Supreme Court and that's it everyone
knows it's our opinion let the public
judge that but then we're on pins and
needles well I mean do we say it's a
fraud we say it's not no there's no been
proven fraud in a court that's true so
but again how do we not even like walk
around eggshells around the edge of that
you can't even give your personal
opinion well I mean you you can but it's
unacceptable opinion you're gone so they
pulled down Scott Adams you guys see
this no Scott Adams had his video pulled
down I don't even know what he said but
he's a he's a look he's got his his
bombastic very Centrist though but he's
he's I think he's very uh he's pretty
little oh man not threatening and yeah
and tame they took one of his videos
down sent him an email saying you're
gone and that's the crazy part is when
they banned something you do or they ban
you you never know what it is and then
once they've banned you I've experienced
this then they can say whatever they
want like Jones won't quit saying this
and most of the time I never even said
that yep but it doesn't matter I have no
voice and so they can say it did they
let's give another example sorry uh like
Laura Loomer right she got banned
everywhere like she became the nominee
for I think the 21st district in Florida
the day she won the Primary as the
Republican nominee they changed the
rules and they didn't say except for
Laura Loomer they said blah blah blah
and they frame it in such a way that you
dig the road right just to have this
person on the far side one gerrymander
yeah yeah one thing they've they've
considered that's exactly right yeah
they say that oh this person was
manipulated using other accounts to
manipulate things that they they won't
prove and you can't defend yourself
against so I guess you can call it
defamation but it never gets anywhere
Twitter just says oh we banned them
because they were operating multiple
accounts behind the scenes well exactly
they call it well I mean here's nothing
happens
I know lots of people I talked to
earlier
in a show before but they banned my
account
I've only talked to you like twice so
these people are getting banned because
they're telling them you work for Alex
Jones just because they promoted
something I was doing it's very very
frightening but but here's what's more
frustrating I just want to say this up
front
I'm not running away from Trump but the
media acts like I got some Bonanza
supporting Trump I got sued persecuted
and banned I'll have more listeners with
Joe Biden it's not like I'm like in some
Trump cult but they made me the Trump
cult leader and so they won't let me not
be that that's what I'm saying yes give
me an example out of you because you can
some to some extent afford it but this
is telling everyone else you're next you
stay in line do you really want do you
want to be a hero you got a family you
got kids we're gonna come for his job
they 100 made me an example and what I'm
telling people is in the process I'm a
tough guy can handle it but I was the
formula for everybody else where once
they platform you they can so let me get
their threats for them it's not that
you've been shut up it's that they can
say whatever they want about you they
can misquote you can't reply you cannot
respond you're like Frozen in The
Phantom Zone like General Zod and
they're out flying around doing whatever
they want but it's not in the fandom
Zone you just get non-comporeal but at a
certain point check it out with this
Hunter Biden stuff they they suppress
the story heavily oh this is oh this
this really grinds my gears I know I I
allowed to go here yeah yeah of course
snapped uh as much as Tim pool can uh
you know I got mad because we went
through big Tech Banning the story
Twitter like literally shut down the New
York Post reporting on this huge story
that Hunter Biden was crooked and and
and those emails were coming out uh
showing that even like Joe was
facilitating this with the flight on Air
Force too and they say it's all fake
news it's all Russian disinfo they
refuse to report refuse to cover it they
don't debunk any of it they say it's not
real and then one month after after the
election what do they do what a
politically explosive story General
blocked it it turns out bar blocked it
during the election exactly and then it
becomes well if it was real average
people if it was real like I've never
heard about it exactly but that's why
well you've heard the hunter Biden tapes
I mean they don't deny they're real but
he's like literally I met with the head
of communist Chinese intelligence
the southern districts gonna indict me
my daddy's scared I mean these are real
tapes and we're like Twitter's like it's
fake blocking it and now it's all
confirmed and I'm gonna put on my Alex
Jones tender foil hat uh the guy who the
you guys saw Mr Project Veritas
um James O'Keefe he had that Jeff
Stucker was the head of CNN they found
his audio they leaked it uh the guy
who's the political director of CNN I
forget the guy's name he had been at
Yahoo news he was fired from Yahoo news
because he said hot Mike got caught with
hot Mike that Mitt Romney doesn't care
if there's a pool full of
African-American kids who drowned so
instead of when someone says something
that outrageous they're not driven out
of town now he runs CNN's political
Department these people always fail up
they do not have consequences it is
their depravity and malfeasance it is
the revolving door and I keep yeah yeah
the incentives are there correct well I
can explain it to you because I work for
these companies let me break it down for
you they're they're always people who
say if you publish a fake story you'll
lose your job look at these guys at CNN
they got fired right and I say right now
there are two guys who worked at
BuzzFeed one guy was caught plagiarizing
one guy was spying on a rival news
organization and then what happens now
they both got rehired at other big firms
there is a guy who I worked with who
killed a huge story about the New York
Times manipulating content and now he
works at the New York Times it's a
revolving door and you know why they
like the Liars there's no Grand
conspiracy between the editors these
companies going we need to find a bunch
of liars it's them seeing someone write
a story that benefits them going I like
stories that benefit me hire the person
who writes things that make me look good
it's all about responding to it they all
go along with the system yeah right
because it's evolutionary
they'll get weeded out the idea that you
can gabate someone like joy and read
back in the day and just have these
really nasty stick kind of like a little
innuendos if you look them up they're
really offensive
um she claims she was hacked and then
called the you say you're going to call
the FBI like if someone calls the FBI
for something they did this person
should be facing legal consequences
instead she gets a promotion and that's
what I think is increasing the case with
uh the average American when they
realize these people are not playing by
the same rules that even remotely port
to anything I understand look at Brian
it was Brian Williams he's saying yeah
and they're like just moving to MSNBC I
guess because you know what they'd
rather but you know why so so he was uh
he was on what NBC News Right was that
Brian Williams and then once they
realized that he was making things up
they were like well who would be more
willing to accept made up things hyper
partisan leftists watching MSNBC so they
moved him over and he carries on it's
it's are you guys familiar with the
Gelman Amnesia effect
uh Michael already no so this is it the
name was made up to sound funny by this
like academic the idea is you you're
reading a newspaper on the front page it
says something in which you are an
expert like it would say Michael Mouse
oh yeah yeah yeah I know so you'll be
like that's not true but then you turn
the page and you see a story about
someone else and you go wow I didn't
know that you forget they lied so you
have these people who seemingly don't
remember that Brian Williams literally
was making things up and going around
and admitted it and they put him on
MSNBC and people are just clapping along
and cheering for it because there's that
quote credibility he's like yes I was a
helicopter shot down by an RPG well I
remember that wrong you know you'd
remember whether you were shot down in
helicopter look at Joe Biden in the 80s
when he was was he was taking the the
life stories of other people well how
did that later because he was running
for president and then he had to resign
in the middle of it and from the
campaign he said I did this to myself
I'm sorry it's wrong basically destroyed
his career but it's not he's about to be
the president probably
and he literally would just take whole
what will he would take the Kennedy
stories
whenever the Kennedy said about
themselves he would composite JFK RFK
and others into his life story and just
repeat total lies and then but back then
he had to step down today like you said
it's not there's so much information
that it is like a form of Amnesia
because they don't remember the people
don't remember this tar read thing just
like was he here and gone how could
people forget because the media the
media uh they they uh memory hold it
they were like it's bad for Biden get it
out of there it's a right-wing
conspiracy theory here's something I
think I'm the first person to break and
I'm gonna break it here I read I got
paid a thousand dollars to read Kamala
Harris's book and in that book she makes
the claim when she was running for
either attorney general or Senator I
think attorney general from California
that a democratic operative
got on stage with her at UC Santa Cruz
somewhere else and said no one named
Kamala and especially from Looney San
Francisco is going to get elected
Statewide in California first of all
after Barack Obama That's absurd second
of all California isn't going to elect
or like a woman with a weird name no one
and this story is in various
organizations political they all
repeated it which she was obviously the
source I try to look up
this would be a huge backlash if anyone
said this to anyone like with a name
like that you can't get elected you
would think that person would be
canceled immediately they've never fact
checked it and it's nowhere online other
than from her
because they don't care their PR firms
we have yeah was it Matt Brainerd who
said that it was a will it was well yes
are you sure yeah I'm sure so that the
news organizations are PR firms will
talks a lot about how he really hates
how everything now is PR pretty sure
that was Matt Brainerd who said the New
York Times is effectively I've heard it
I've heard it it seems like it's been
propaganda the whole way down since the
Inception of human history except for
little bouts of Freedom like the
American Revolution when they didn't
have a central bank for a short period
of time before the United States got
re-coopted who was the the president who
like shut down the first one was that
Jackson yeah that was Andrew Jackson
yeah yeah they were man I killed the
bank all I know is you got an incredible
Steakhouse down the street and they
tried to kill the guy oh is that well we
shouldn't say what it is but uh but so
let's do this let's do this because
we're definitely getting ahead let me
just here in Missouri aliens yeah in
Missouri Missouri Let's uh let's uh I
just want to read you guys what's
happened with the Texas court case
because I know uh uh we're gonna open
this we kind of a big deal check it out
so I got the actual uh filing here from
Supreme Court dot gov they say Texas V
Pennsylvania the state of Texas's motion
for leave to file a bill of complaint is
denied for lack of standing under
article 3 of The Constitution Texas has
not demonstrated a judicially cognizable
interest in the manner in which another
state conducts elections all other
pending motions are dismissed as moot
statement of Justice Alito with whom
Justice Thomas joins quote in my view we
do not have discretion to deny the
filing of Bill of complaint in a case
that falls within our general
jurisdiction see Arizona V California
589 at U.S
I would therefore Grant the motion to
file the bill of complaint but would not
Grant other relief and I expressed no
view on any other issue and then they
also note Goldman Sachs uh of the AR
teacher retirement was a Satori was
granted I don't know that that cases but
that it's kind of funny to see Goldman
Sachs uh versus the teacher retirement
below Ian's face he's like what yeah
that's on the document too for whatever
reason I don't know uh but so this I'm
not gonna just give people positive news
I mean I think clearly there have been
anomalies there's been problems with
accepting these 80 million mailed out
ballots that was the Democrat strategy
they said
we're going to hold up this election we
think there's going to be a red Mirage
where it looks like Trump wins we're
gonna be counting for months and even if
he looks like he wins we will not accept
his inauguration uh we are going to have
our own inauguration that's what uh John
podesta said of the New York Times all
that went on as soon as Trump has a
problem he says I'm going to challenge
this oh it's terrible it's crazy and
Matthew McConaughey said that last week
with Russell Brandt you know he said
listen Maybe the Republicans are in
denial Trump lost whatever
but to act like it's crazy
for them to challenge this when that's
all you did at the last election you
tried to block the electors then you
said he was a Russian agent that's a
fraud so everyone saw that unfold but I
will just say this I talked to White
House lawyers I talked to other top
constitutional lawyers they said the
other suits aren't that good the Texas
case is the best and they said if this
goes down it goes from a Hail Mary to a
superhail Mary so I'm not going to sit
here and sell people uh Pie in the Sky I
I think we've gone to about a 90 chance
now uh that Trump's going to have to
capitulate it's more than 90 because
there's no organizational will from the
Republicans to do this exactly well
there was 120 126 Republicans in the
house signed on if you can I mean they
don't care I think it's 99 I I've been
saying it's 99.9 for Biden for the past
you know no you have been but I mean
isn't that because it's the illusion
that he's elected he's had the signs up
he's done it and and so they finally
said he's a Russian agent he's going to
be gone didn't work he's a Ukrainian he
did it didn't work but finally they use
the election as a way to whatever really
happened to say Trump's done and I and I
and I think just the perception of all
our other elections that somebody when
somebody loses that that's what's going
to happen to Trump and and so the
question is Republicans aren't going to
cry and scream and and throw fits in the
streets like the left did four years ago
like toddlers but what is going to
happen this country before we went live
both of you guys were saying you think
it really looks at societal historical
Division and at least divorce yeah
you're not the first person to come here
and say that either I am the first I
wrote an article about this in April
2016. all right all right saying uh it's
time to disunite the states that we've
been held together with thumbtacks and
strings since the beginning there's at
least two countries here and we've only
got held together and one invaded and
had occupied the other half
um it's ridiculous that people uh David
Corn I think from the nation he's a big
hardcore Cathedral operative he was
tweeting out oh you know Republicans are
trying to destroy democracy and have a
coup every election is a coup every
election is a lot of people do not want
this person it's electoral War yeah okay
yeah and because you have more people
therefore I get nothing and I gotta sit
at home and shut up no I'm not gonna no
in a republic everybody knows this we'll
stay there for those that don't if 51
vote in a reconnaissance Republic to
enslave the other 49 you can't have it
but in a democracy they had blackstones
and white stones in ancient Greece and
routinely they would vote to kill
somebody they didn't like what they had
to say and a 51 said kill you they did
in a republic folks we protect property
we protect life we protect self-defense
and we say hey there's certain things
enshrined you can't do this may be
misattributed to Benjamin Franklin but
the quote is quite proudly is
misattributed no Benjamin Franklin
Public if you can keep it Revenger and
Franklin wrote an essay about what you
should be proud to fart I'm not kidding
okay well anyway with a quote no quote I
was going to say is democracy is two
wolves and a lamb deciding on what's for
lunch they did two wolves and a sheep
decided a republic is a well-armed sheep
uh contesting the vote yeah that I think
that he did say that yeah say that again
I'm ruin it interrupted it democracy is
two wolves and a sheep deciding on
what's for lunch
a republic is a well-armed sheep
contesting the vote and republics aren't
invulnerable like the Republican
oligarchy of Rome was eventually the
military commander just took it over and
turned it which is Julius Caesar
Crossing the Rubicon but it was treason
already trying to open the Republic that
forced him to do that I'm about to
finish Julius Caesar but it's what I'm
saying people say well General Flynn
said we need martial law and Linwood so
we need martial law and people are like
oh my God I'm up for martial law but
we're already under blue state blue City
Marshalls yeah we are yeah right and so
this is something we were actually
talking about like a couple days ago
yeah who brought that up there like was
it will who said we're already under
martial law I was like you get these
isn't it it's crazy to hear people
calling updates on your phone telling
you what to do don't go outside your
house it's outside regular law regular
law suspended uh yeah regular First
Amendment to the Constitution people
know about freedom of speech and
religion it says the right to Freedom
free uh peaceably assembled it doesn't
say why yeah it says if I'm good I could
get together with people nothing's more
people there's nothing more peaceful
than a holiday dinner with your family
or maybe it's less people it says
Congress shall make no law yeah respect
the establishment of religion or
prohibit the free exercise thereof or
the people's right to piece of symbol or
the press or of all you have no rights
government does not have a goddamn
jurisdiction right and they're just
completely brazenly ignoring I'll tell
you which I'm sorry if the government
can just say well it's an emergency so
we do what we want then what the heck's
the point of the Constitution it's like
a man raping a woman a man does not or a
woman raping a man or a man raping a man
you don't have jurisdiction you have to
agree to it and so literally this is
like rape when they when they say you
don't have a right to go out but we do
and then they exercise their rights and
we don't they're doing that on purpose I
think I think the first and most
important thing for people to understand
too is it's against the science it's
it's the World Health organization's top
doctor came out a while ago and said is
the last of Last Resorts and it should
be avoided and it can be avoided they
had you in Envoy said lockdowns we were
wrong
starving millions and even Melinda Gates
came out yesterday and said we didn't
know this would cause a collapse a
million stars 272 million are expected
to starve to death in the third world in
the next year I checked that YouTube I
was saying that 10 months ago so so what
I'm telling you is the lockdown whether
it's real or exaggerated whatever it is
is causing because in the first world
okay we we lose our pension or or you
don't have as big a house or maybe you
lose a few pounds in the third world a
breakdown and a lockdown causes
starvation and death so when the West
goes into depression the third world
dies and we're talking about real black
lives matter here and in other lives all
over the world poor people are starving
to death right now was it in I think it
was Mali or some African country Malawi
one of those two where they were said
all right you're gonna have a lockdown
even they had no covet and they go if we
don't Farm today we don't have food
tomorrow
that's a good saying if we don't Farm
today we have no food tomorrow I don't
know if there is we don't Farm today
as pithy as me because you know
we don't Farm we'll die within a month
yeah okay it's an interesting saying
that could apply in any any form but let
me stop interrupting because I've sped
this up start over Tim you start over
the New York Times The Washington Post
admit a billion people set to go into
total poverty possible starvation two
million already starved to death 200 to
something million I forget the exact
number are on the verge of starvation
because the lockdown not the damn virus
that's only killed a million worldwide
so let's talk about that can I go full
Alex Jones no but I mean I mean I'm
gonna go full Alex Jones I'm sure you've
been talking about this before and
you're not the first there has been for
decades uh beating the drums for having
full-scale wealth distribution from the
first world to the third world this has
been a thing that they've been arguing
for a very long time we need to jack up
taxes in in Europe
right and now now they have a reason
look all these people but they're not
really going to give them anything I
know but this is this is a great cover
this is the greatest oh you're right you
don't want these people in Africa do you
want them to be starving
that they've all this is this is it oh
sorry go ahead and make your point that
was my point let's just get this Pope
Francis is on board with the massive
multinational billion dollar
corporations for the great reset but let
me start over because this is so
important and I wasn't going to go here
because it's so serious but so I wanted
to have a lighthearted thing about UFOs
and stuff but start over you can pull
this up this fact check this because I
don't get the numbers wrong the U.N says
like 200 in YouTube I don't have a
perfect memory like 230 something
million people 272. sorry 272 are about
to starve to death 2 million already
started to death the last 10 months is
what I read the New York Times 2 million
yeah like a week ago I read it who knows
what that's real the point is is that I
know folks are in the third world it's
bad
like you said I mean it's it's bad these
lockdowns are bad
so I'm saying if it kills a hundred
times more people having a lockdown we
need to stop this I mean and this is
what kills the whole malthusian lockdown
and that's very uh globally ethically
thinking of you right being concerned
about how these other countries are
faring because of what they're doing in
these countries right
I'm saying like I'm saying it's not
agree they're humans if I want if we if
we want this is the thing we often hear
that these people uh you know like the
great reset which is published on the
world economic Forum website they're
like we're gonna rethink capitalism and
redo this to make it better for
everybody because for too long this this
that and this and the bad things if I
actually like I don't actually believe
these people when they say they're
trying to do the right thing because
they're doing right by them exactly and
it's an excuse when the pope comes out
and says MasterCard and visa and these
big companies are are going to redo
capitalism the right way I'm like
they're the ones who have exploited it
with crony corporatism and revolving
doorposts it's like going to Hitler to
learn how to fight Nazis Hitler killed a
lot of Nazis though well I guess you're
right I killed the worst ones he purges
on people you're right okay and he
killed Hitler
okay sorry the worst one it's like going
to Stalin to learn how I don't know
killed Nazis too they were the first
ones to ruin Alex come on get it
together I thought you were gorilla I
wasn't going to the Nazi stuff I meant
it's like going to a fox to learn how to
guard A Hymn house but I guess there you
go there you go learn how to guard the
house because the fox hold on hold on I
mean Fox could probably tell you
what I'm saying let him keep trying till
he gets it goes
he just said it he just said it but it's
cheating when he says it they're the
worst offenders telling us how they're
the moral Authority and then in real
practice their lockdown is imploding us
and the third world for them I got it
it's like hiring the fox to guard your
Hen House yes because truth be told if
you if you've got a hen house and you
hire a fox fox I'll tell you exactly how
I broke in and everybody that's a good
point that's why I got to secure if you
hire the fox the guy that had asked you
wake up you got no hens left you know
exactly why so it goes back to the
original saying no it is it's the fox
let's just say this it's hiring Satan to
stop the devil I mean it's like they're
the guys doing all this and then we're
like they're like we're gonna fix the
problems their very policies are
destroying and killing people
consolidating power but they go it's
okay did you did you see the pineapple
Hill video pineapple Hill Cafe oh yeah
out of California what's this this is a
woman and she's outside of her
restaurant oh yeah yeah yeah she's got
this we've brought up a million times by
the way we've talked to her we can air
this she'll let you hear it I mean we we
should play it Go and tell people she
talks about how they have an outdoor
dining area it's like his big gazebo
tent and picnic tables she shows it she
shows it the state said unacceptable
can't open 50 feet away is Food Services
for Hollywood production same exact
setup totally okay hold on hold on she
separates the tables more they have
these huge tents 50 feet away like you
said what did she say in the video
everything I own is being stolen from me
the world economic Forum published a
great reset video I think it was four
years ago four years and they said in
2030 you will own nothing nothing and
you will be happy I'm sorry you're right
so when we see all of these things that
the the the end result is stripping away
ownership rights of the poor but the
rich are doing better than ever think
about think about who's next making
record profit that's the thing the
middle class is being disenfranchised
the poor is being starved to death yeah
the third world's been killed and the
people doing are going I'm so liberal
look the popes on our side we love you
we're gonna lock everything down for a
couple more years all right and you're
like and when everything implodes we're
gonna put you on a universal income and
make you take vaccines to get the money
do you see what uh what what Joe uh Joe
Biden's plan is for kovid no is it the
Krampus pants 100 days of the mask and
it's basically what we've already been
doing yes Scott Adams me at that point
yeah yeah it's so he's like if everybody
just wear a mask to be done and it's
like but the we've been wearing masks 10
months but their argument is some people
didn't follow it it's her fault but
Sweden has the studies other have the
studies Mainline scientists they go well
it's not the U.N scientist well wait the
UN said lock everything down 10 months
ago they did it now the U.N says we were
wrong don't lock things down it's
causing a chain reaction but still the
bureaucracies do it and then the other
scientists say the match don't protect
you well whether it's true or not those
scientists have a right to a voice to
say that I was told by YouTube that as
long as we adhere to what the World
Health Organization says we're good and
if you go against the World Health
Organization you're spreading this
information then a top World Health
Organization scientists came out and
said lockdowns are bad and we should not
do them so what am I supposed to say now
because the governors are doing the
opposite of what the World Health
Organization told us to do and what I'm
supposed to be a lot of times so that's
a question to both of you why are they
the British came out yesterday the
British government said okay we're
suspending shots for under 16 for
pregnant women and people have any type
of allergies because we're having you
know Bell's palsy and it can only be
administered in a facilitate facility
with resuscitation measures readily
available wow so I'm not listen listen
when I tweeted that I had people calling
me an anti-vaxxer and I'm like I am
tweeting you the nhs's official publicly
declared statement to keep people safe
so that's my next question were you
criticizing yourself I'm asking that's
what I'm saying what's the Paradox here
where they're like oh sorry we've
suspended the Australian shots for false
positive HIV test and now oh we're
suspending the shots because it's
hurting people and then we're still full
of crap no the truth is vaccines have
always had pros and cons and when you
accelerate my biggest criticism with
Trump was him getting on board with warp
speed and going oh you want two years
I'll do it in six months and now this
stuff's killing people you want to get
on Trump's ass there it is right there
but now the left won't do that remember
just hearing the the campaign though are
there are there actually death I think
there's side effects well no what they
argue is they go in all these deaths in
Europe in the UK and Australia they the
big farmer runs it so they go well we
had six people die in this study and
four die in that study and two die in
the study but we're saying we can't
prove they die for the vaccine
I need hard data on that stuff because
here's what I can you pull it up you can
pull it up so
just the important thing is I think
letting people know the very very
specific government statements about
anaphylaxis and Bell's Palsy like
these things are coming from the energy
well let me give you some real headlines
let's do this 59 die in South Korea
after flu shot pull it up okay let's
pull up another headline this is just
this week this is this week uh here's
another headline
um I mean there's so many of these uh
47 homeless die after being given flu
shot Poland uh I mean these are all real
headlines uh this is I see this in the
news feed AP Reuters but it's never a
big national news story it's like they
cover the fine print okay we're
admitting it but here it is and it just
comes up and it comes out of his is
right yes well so so I'm trying to find
a Microsoft approved Source because you
yeah so much oh Scott
well so I don't know how we uh we I
actually had a plan for segwaying into
aliens okay because it was supposed to
not get too serious like we got to talk
about this code aliens are real but uh
but but let's get this
why did today or nice yesterday now in
Australia why did they stop Nationwide
all their vaccinations their government
approved vaccine which is an mRNA
vaccine that goes into your very DNA
because the people that take it are
having false positives they hope they're
false positives for HIV
now now I told so this is the New York
Times by the way that Alex is citing
here Australia scraps covid-19 vaccine
that produced HIV false positives wow
right and this is the T-cell Council so
that's what happened guys I took a
covid-19 vaccine that's why I had that
positive test results of the dozens of
chronovirus vaccines being tested
worldwide the one under development at
the University of Queensland was the
first to be abandoned
that's the official Rush this thing's so
fast but I gotta tell you Trump trump
did Trump in all serious operation I
mean I mean I've said this Trump's
biggest thing is is how he said oh I'll
unlock the economy I'll warp speed it
and I tried to like halfway try to
figure out maybe he's trying to take
control of the Rockefellers and from
Gates and he wants to have the regular
vaccine the business is dangerous that
actually just takes the attenuated virus
and no he pushed the MRNA and I'm not
turning on Trump now he's in trouble
I've been criticizing him for months
eight months the MRNA vaccine is the is
a new form of vaccine it goes in
reprograms the cells it's it's a mutagen
normally you only have this in your body
when you have cancer or when you're a
baby in your mother growing so this goes
in in program cells to actually mutate
and so I'm like what's going on why are
they doing this this is insane this is
how the Ninja Turtles happened
well that was uh actually the Ninja
Turtles was the the the chemical that
was being shipped in um through an
Alleyway that spilled into what's his
Face's eyes Splinter no no no no no
um Baxter Stockton Murdoch Matthew
Murdoch is that his name Daredevil so
yeah you guys understand though you guys
understand
right now as we know this you need to
Wolfgang wodog is the head elected
Global commission EU science advisor
like he's the good fouchy he got with
over 100 scientists one of them was the
former science head of of Pfizer they
filed suit in the EU on December 1st
said we've looked at the studies on the
MRNA Pfizer vaccine alone
and it'll either turn your immune system
off and drop T cells down to zero
because these huge papers they attach
it's like I don't understand
hieroglyphics but these are like
procedure scientists or it'll Jack it up
and cause it a cytokine storm
and it looks like it attacks a placenta
in women because the same protein in
this virus is the same Protein that's
fast growing in the placenta and they
said it looks like it might give people
HIV that was six seven days ago Dude you
I'm not a scientist I read the paper and
six seven days later it's in the New
York Times that that is giving people
false positive HIV so here's the deal
fact check this I don't know what's
going on but I'm scared
you know like let's play Devil's
Advocate if you have vaccine that cures
a potentially deadly virus and the
consequence is like your AIDS tests
aren't going to be reliable for like a
few months is that really that bad of a
side effect but why is it because the
original when the Indian scientist in
March late February their main Indian
Technical Institute the only Indian
school you know they got good scientists
that bought the Crispers it's worth
billions of dollars they have a
multi-billion dollar crispr Gene editing
reader electron microscope crisper
what's a crisper just Gene editing Gene
editing I don't understand I read this
stuff they said hey this is a very
dangerous Chimera five viruses HIV
delivery system and they said it's not
art it's not it's not naturally
occurring it's synthetic who said that
this is the top Indian University they
said it's got It's got Gene edited pea
shuttle Gene where they cut this in and
they go so complex it's above anything
we've even got this is like secret level
stuff of course it came out of the U.S
Chapel Hill Obama fauci five six years
ago it was illegal in the U.S they moved
into Wuhan they even came out in
Newsweek you pull it up uh fauci funded
uh we heard last time fauci funded um
North Carolina or South Carolina yeah
yeah yeah secretly legal gain of
function stuff North Carolina fauci
funded controversial uh gain of function
Wuhan lab
and so the Indians scanned it and the
Germans scanned it then the Australians
scanned it and then others scanned it
and I had Dr Francis Boyle on my show
today the guy that wrote the U.S
biological weapons law and helped route
the U.N treaty and he said Laura he's he
prosecuted Sullivan milanovic he's like
a head U.N prosecutor and he said no the
Australians he was just on Australian TV
yesterday on on their National TV on Sky
TV they reverse engineered off the
crispr scan and made this new vaccine
and so when they copied it and made a
vaccine out of it that's why HIV shows
up this is a copy of the covid which has
been attenuated
a bit esoteric for me yeah
I gotta so I can tell you about just
like the surface level just one of the
reasons why I think it's important to
talk about the the UK's warning on like
people under 16 and you know that's
confirm that's not debatable but but
it's just get people like listen listen
this is an official thing you know I'm
not saying this to scare anybody I'm
trying to make sure you know exactly
what the National Health Service is
telling people they're going to be
proving in the U.S take this up into
consideration and judge for yourself but
these are like official Health uh
warnings why is the British government
so one weekend to giving the shot one
weekend of giving the shot why are they
certainly saying under 16 don't take it
have an allergic response don't take it
um pregnant don't take it why are they
backtracking because this is the trial
they're they're experimenting this what
was it right now and and but but I think
I think it's a little bit of an exact
it's not necessarily an exaggeration
it's this whole thing was rushed through
to the point where we didn't go through
years of Trials where they could have
control the groups and study Russians
that yes yes and what is wrong solo so
they rushed it they rushed it so now
remember Luke Skywalker says why at the
rate they're gaining or the Star
Destroyers chasing him off canceling
when they fly off from Lost Eisley he
says hurry up he goes too fast kid you
bounce off a Star supernova that'll end
your trick real quick so so we've gone
at warp speed and we've actually run
into Supernova here Star Wars man so do
you think aliens are real yeah smooth
transition yeah such a smooth Segway
listen let's finish up let's not
butchered that no we can talk oh you're
right we need to calculate where we're
going before we hit warp drive yeah yeah
it reminds me what what was it the
original Star Wars where they're like if
you warp from here you might crash into
something is that what you're talking
about he's like look Skywalker's like
why aren't we going quicker the starter
she goes dude we gotta calculate the
have computer or we'll go too close to a
store or bounce off a supernova and
we're dead real quick go through a star
right yeah exactly so yeah I forget the
exact quote but I mean that's what like
Trump's like warp speed with no no
Direction
yeah and then and then he gets blamed
with all the [ __ ] that happened sorry I
wonder if this is we talked about it
last time a little bit that some people
look at Humanity or humans as a
liability and that some people think
like we can survive with this gross
population we can keep growing it and
growing it and we'll figure out ways to
sustain other people are like it's too
many people we have to just assume
there's going to be calculated losses
let's move forward and what you're
saying is that we're all here having
normal debates about life and Friends
being normal the globalist it's all
about do we exterminate most of people
to save the Earth or do we have this
expansionist View and within that is the
debate of the malthusian system or the
Plato system of call the public versus
the laissez-faire expansionist system
and there's those two debates at the
highest levels and the globalist
exterminist view is gaining the four and
is the dominant World System
who made the Georgia Guidestones
Ted Turner is actually on record funding
those do you have you want to do it so
my friends my friends we have a a gift
from Luke radkowski he's actually
sitting in the room he's just chilling
but uh it's a game called it's a game
called that's right well I thought he
was your kid but anyway there's a card
game it's a trivia game and there's a
bunch of different conspiracy theory
trivia questions so Michael actually has
a bunch of the cards we were I'm gonna
tell everybody exactly what the plan was
when we were going to do this so when
Alex and I were talking after the last
episode got pulled from YouTube we were
on the phone and Alex mentioned that the
the air has been sucked out of the room
and that where's the opportunity to talk
about you know DMT aliens space programs
and all that fun conspiracy stuff that
like we got so entrenched in politics
and I was like dude I agree let's let's
and then and then Joe Rogan told me he
was going to do that I love Joe I get in
his Studio you know what happened you
know what happened Alex walks in and
then I get I look at my tweet and it's
like scotus rules against Texas and I'm
like oh dude Maybe
current events are so crazy like they're
suspended the Australian because of the
covet vaccine because of HIV that's
weird that's the New York Times I pulled
it up like it's it's in the New York
Times
I gotta stop you
I'm going to tell you something that's
going to blow your mind all right
do you know what Monday is
no Monday is uh December 14th it happens
on December 14th
do you guys do you know on the fifth
take they're gonna start certifying the
electors and that's the 14th on the 14th
they do the uh the elector's vote we're
also going to have a meteor shower full
solar eclipse and a comet see how I
guess it is
within the 14th of 21st we are going to
see the uh conjunction of Jupiter the
Christmas story and the Christmas star
oh wow so only ever 800 years whoa so uh
I'm not a superstitious no it's a
globalist or obsessed with planetary
alignments but but like every everything
that's happening it's not been there's
no orchestration behind the fact that
the meteor shot and the comet are coming
on this day that's what they want you to
believe Tim fool oh yeah you're living
in an electric universe
I just read the news
isn't it crazy though like so so when I
heard the Romans wouldn't go to war
unless Mars was in the right like deal
and as soon as Mars came around every
whatever they would like go to war so I
mean every culture was obsessed with the
planets there's the have you heard the
electric universe theory that all forces
are actually magnetism gravity is like a
resonating frequency of magnetism well
it's as above so below the Alchemy is
everything is a model of below it above
it and so everything's connected somehow
the same models over and over again
definitely it seems like like an atom
looks like a solar system you know you
have a central nuclei with uh orbiting
As Above So Below do you guys remember
that viral video of the young woman the
great lady who the grape lady grape lady
who's that that was like the first viral
video no no no no that woman on a
treadmill about a month sucks dancing
baby I believe was one of the versions
there's a there's a young woman and
she's doing this Tick Tock video and
she's like Biden is having accesses in
his seventh house and this means he's
gonna win and the peak period it's like
this crazy astrology stuff well Biden
ended up you know at least winning as
far as uh as as where we're at right now
but she says the the Jupiter Saturn
conjunction is coming it's a Once in an
800 year cycle and this means a dramatic
change to the rule to the system of
ruling in the United States you know I
bring up a magnetic Universe because if
the orbiting structure of all of this is
magnetic and our brains have magnetic
neurons and our stomachs have magnetic
neurons we're being well that's how
birds and bees don't fly thousands of
miles off magnetic lines they now have
proven we have magnetic cells in our
brains and we're probably acting like
those hordes of bees just if you zoomed
out far enough and could look at it
functionally you'd see us we mass in
these cities like arterial uh
combination uh hey Alex performing a
terrible act that is publicly blamed on
another organization or country it's
called what a false flag that's correct
yes does what does he get for answering
the question correctly uh you get a
Mountain Dew
how about some of that uh what do you
got there oh no that's it for later oh
I'll give us another one Mike
am bringing up this like weird Stars
phenomenon is it just people making a
joke about the day the Electoral College
is being certified that that the the
media are any coincidences
the the ones in an 800 year Jupiter
Saturn conjunction no the planets are
going to come together aligned creating
one bright star like looking it's the
planets but you'll see a bright light in
the sky bigger than you ever seen that
movie Master Commander no I haven't
pretty good really much space on a
O'Brien novel but which was based on
real Naval histories of England but
they've got this guy on board they're
having bad luck and as soon as he's dead
I throw him overboard the wind comes
back and the ship can go on and he looks
over at the ship's doctor and he says
matcher and not everything's in your
books and so there's just a lot of words
a lot of weird interconnected stuff in
the universe that we can all pick up on
we know is going on but there's no way
to quantify it because our site is so
you know the whole light spectrum we
barely see one point on him yeah plus
there's all these other dimensions we're
basically he's blind creatures and only
see in a very limited deal so we're only
picking up how the rest of it operates I
was talking to uh I'm gonna be very
vague on this but let me I'll just say
you know after we did the show last time
because we we talked about the elves and
and you know DMT and stuff machinos
machine elves and I was talking to
Michael afterwards and I told him about
a very specific coincidence I don't want
a name because I could give away some
personal details but I mentioned like
some weird thing happened where some
numbers aligned in a very strange way
like the exact same time you remember
what yeah and it was really really
really what I guess what you call it
serendipitous that's not the right word
is it yeah yeah weird things very very
weird things and and it seems like
throughout my life at least in my
anecdotal you know uh experience there
have been weird things that pop up from
time to time not in a great number of
times the point where I'd become
superstitious or religious other people
have these weird things happen all the
time listen I have dreams because I got
a lot of political success a lot of
stuff but not be less how am I
successful I go with what I think's
right but I have had dreams and their
dreams always had like a really sweaty I
get upset I hardly ever have a weird
dream or I wake up like anxiety attack
like I've been somewhere else
when I was younger it happened more
which is what all the literature says
you're more excited when you're young
you're more attuned to the universe
because you get more control over
yourself as you get older you learn to
block out the universe but I've had
dreams that exactly come true and it's
always like a car wreck being mugged
someone dying and then you're I mean I
told people about this stuff and then
later see me it's not like I had some
one left side right side Deja Vu or one
side sees it first the other side sees
it and you go wait I've already seen
that this is stuff where I've said hey a
guy in a purple and green striped shirt
pulls a knife out and and stabs me in
the arm and I beat his brains out with
that happen in real life yeah and then
like a few months later I was that a
dream it was a dream I kept waking up
having it like sweating and then
I'm buying beer when I'm like 16 for
girls and we're in Dallas and we're
buying beer illegally in the bad part of
town and then we're parked at the back
of the liquor store and so I come back
around on this and this white hobo guy
in the same shirt attacks me stabs me in
the arm I beat his brains out whole nine
yards wait do you have a scar yeah no
just blow meow but the point is what
noise did you just make what
was that gorilla Noise
Okay that's easy but the point is I've
had that dream like it was nauseating
because I got when I had those psychic
dreams like I've been to another
dimension like I time traveled like I
folded space and I would wake up and
never have these dreams hardly ever but
I know if I wake up and I'm sweating and
I start puking like I've been to another
dimension it's always in the future and
it's it's it's heavy man
what about you Michael uh I think the
way it's been explained to me like if I
write down these three numbers 13 9 3
and 8 right it's not going to mean
anything to anyone it's just like random
numbers but if I go through the alphabet
and I tell you that the 13th of the
alphabet is M and the ninth letter of
the alphabet is I and the third letter
is C and the eighth letter is H the next
in this series would be a my name
Michael which would be a one right so if
you knew this code
you would be able to figure out predict
the next thing the pattern but that
pattern had been there lately the whole
time it like even if you never knew
about it it still would have flowed
automatically so when you take these
kind of substances is my understanding
your perceiving patterns that other
people are oblivious to and here's a
perfectly rational example of this this
is house you're talking about DMT or I
don't there's a lot of LSD LSD all of it
here's another very very simple example
everyone understands which is uh uh
stock market Traders right if I know the
market and I see this BMW stock should
be forty dollars but it's trading at 30.
I know okay this is a buy it's going to
go up whereas if you don't know the
stock market these numbers aren't going
to mean anything to you right so it's
about different forms of knowledge and
being able to perceive information and
just like one last Point everyone knows
this if you look around this room do you
see this this four of us here there's a
bunch of people over there there's
spooky ghosts but we tune out so much
and this is that's where I was going
it's a it's an evolutionary development
as a baby that we can only see a narrow
light spectrum and not the
electromagnetic because we're filtering
it out because we can't handle it as we
get older we learn spiritually or
through the Pioneer and all the rest of
it to start engaging more of it but but
then a lot of folks go crazy because
interfacing with that is too much wise
while we have an evolutionary
development to block it out I won't said
there were ghosts that's a joke what oh
I woke up I was like can you can see
them too let me tell you let me tell you
an insider trading story this isn't like
Martha Stewart we hear a super big story
it'll be a big story no story no I mean
I'll tell you a story Joe Rogan's a
great guy I'm only 22 years
he calls me up like six months ago and
he goes yeah I made the decision to go
to Spotify don't tell anybody for about
three months and then you went and just
I don't know I haven't told I told part
of it yeah
that was that was a conversation a month
later I guess part of that's true yes I
forgot he called you about it yes you
know you know I forgot what a small
world maybe it's all just me you and Joe
Rogan and no one else exists Michael Mr
malice that's all you're all just in
NPCs no no but seriously he goes yeah
I'm looking at houses where should I
look blah blah I'm sick of the
censorship I'm gonna move over can I say
this yeah you can say all this except
I'm moving to Austin and then it was
kind of some you know a lot of heat on
and I I might have embellished it a bit
so I I backed off what I said because I
don't want to get Joe in trouble Joe
Rogan's moving to Mars
I have the documents there's a moon base
well I I knew years ago the Elon Musk
already lived outside Austin okay
he already lived there well I mean he's
Rich enough he's got rocky races in
South Texas North Texas I mean yeah yeah
he's got yeah he's got houses there but
yeah no people know him he's he's I
don't want to say where he lives he
lives right outside Austin he's got a
ranch and that's where he lives about
half the time now but but that's a side
issue
so the story Joe I'm sitting there on my
boat I got my kids on the boat I got
some friends hold on hold on what's your
book called that's Alexis she's a little
little what's it called it doesn't have
a name it's a blue uh ski boat can you
give it a name now come on it's a 26
foot motorboat it doesn't have a name
it's gonna have a bigger boat little
little Jones he doesn't have a name call
it doctor mouth anyway yeah just please
finish it's a blue boat
okay well usually little boats don't
have names on them it says I don't just
I don't agree with Michael's wearing a
blue shirt
Governors to getmo.com
all right all right please Alex continue
your story this is a real story all
right
because so you know this you've talked
to Joe you you do this and you never
thought like this I bet money Tim pool
like well let me ask you this question
when did Joe tell you he was going to
Spotify because all you guys are friends
you talk a lot when she's told me that
you told me that I found out after the
news broke wow okay so I guess you're
not friends no no hold on this was live
on the show this was this was live on
the show uh you made an announcement
about Joe Rogan and Spotify and then we
were gonna do a show and uh I ended up I
texted Joe because I wanted to make sure
I had confirmation and during the show
Joe called me and you left for 30
minutes I was right yeah and I got up
and I went outside and talked to Joe
about it I came home to eat dinner and
my wife was here downstairs she's like
she's cooking dinner watching it I'm
like hey Kim pool says you're full of
crap that's basically what happened yeah
yeah News Guard approved well no I mean
Joe got listen he was so angry he was
yelling on the phone that's no I'm
kidding all right but let me let me get
the big part
Joe doesn't think like this neither do
you but I'm sitting there as a joke
because I'm on this boat with these
people and I knew they would pay
attention to me and so Joe calls me goes
yeah I've made the deal I'm leaving
I want to announce for a couple of
months I'm moving to Austin I'm going to
close on a place in a couple weeks but
you know don't tell anybody but I'm
gonna go to Spotify I go okay buddy
that's great I won't tell anybody hang
up and I'm sitting there while these
people that are friends with the family
they're nice lawyers but they think they
know everything and they're talking
about stocks and stuff later and I go
you know I bet Spotify is going to go up
they're totally ignoring me it's like
crack a beard I'm like all right and I
knew that info but I'm not in the stock
market who are you with just some
lawyers and family I just love the idea
that's your family and you're giving
them useful information they basically
like taking classes to ignore you and
they're like oh yeah
oh they're swimming on the back they're
drinking beer whatever what's the book
called it doesn't yeah so I'm sitting
there
you just had it with me yeah
it's a real story come on come on come
on
my sixth sense of humor is Joe Rogan
have a 10-minute conversation
I know he's going to Spotify for sure he
signed the deal he just told me but
don't tell anybody so I'm sitting there
and they're talking about stocks in
there I bought this house here and it's
gone up five percent oh really my 401k
this and I just was a joke because I
never talk about I go you know I bet
Spotify it's gonna be really big it's
like oh
meanwhile I didn't go invest in Spotify
I knew that was going on I didn't tell
anybody I owe no stock it doubled when
that was announced in one day it was
huge and now it's even up more so you
could have I mean you could have made a
billion dollars at what point is he put
in prison but the point was I knew that
Intel that's why this information
survival would you go to prison if you
bought stock on that no I don't know no
yeah well there's no the stock could
have gone down because he's not an
Insider insiders when you work for the
company no I agree and Joe is
controversial You could argue this I
could go down because like last night
not a good argument I agree I agree so
why didn't I do it because it's black
magic
Pam only had my strength because I never
engaged in it and here's how I work if I
start watching sports all I do is watch
sports if I start doing something it's
I'm obsessed with it so I can't invest
even though with my knowledge of stuff
and my Insider knowledge I can make a
ton of money do you meditate I need to
dude if you meditate you're gonna
vibrate White Energy across the universe
well I'm ready to do it right now with
temple my wife's trying to get me to do
it oh the plants stopped levitating look
at that the plant's gone but no but the
thing stopped levitating it's because
someone was not trying it's just it's a
that's that's how they were trying but
how cool he was trying to get pizza and
they not think about insider trading
they're not hearing me what could we
have done but Joe's a great guy he
trusted me with that information he had
Dave Smith on instead of me he's not
that great okay very failed comedian I
know I was supposed to be on before the
election and then he just like leave me
hanging so let me tell you though
with Joe Rogan and Tim Dillon was
amazing yeah were you the middle of that
Human Centipede
yes I was you think that's the worst
part what do they call the lucky guy in
the middle no no no it's not the worst
part of course it is the end is the
worst part how
do you want me to go into detail about
the digestive system by the way it comes
out of the person the middle guys having
the same thing by the way yes but the
middle I guess fake news I did not have
sex with him oh my gosh I guess you're
right because the person middle dies
right away in the human centipede
from from not right away but they'll go
into septic shock no I thought they did
the thing and basically that you can
survive because they're like feeding
that so Tim do you think what Joe Rogan
told me he was going to going to Spotify
why are we talking about human Center
because he was in one with Tim Dylan Joe
Rogan to have the documents oh my gosh
so what is that can you imagine that
pay-per-view oh my gosh people are like
paper not view like I will give you
money not to show this to me exactly
I'm only having some fun man do you
think that how did we were talking about
uh
how did we get into the stock in Joe
Rogan no I was giving an example of
Insider knowledge
I actually know all about coven I know
where it's going all the stuff
I got I wanted to say something to what
you were talking about these numbers I
was once sitting at a Starbucks in New
York City and I was sitting at the
window bar having like a coffee and
right across the street I could see a
wall with black streaks going across it
in an upward and arching angle and I
looked at it and laughed I know exactly
what it is it's wall ride marks from a
skateboard but I realized I was like
this was this is a long time ago maybe
like 10 years ago I was like there are a
ton of people who probably walk past
that and say where did these scuff marks
come from no because like did a bicycle
ride it's a perfect example you have the
Practical knowledge they don't they
don't read the language but so it's like
I see a totally different world from
them yes based on what I know yes
exactly and I'm so sick I like friends I
like family I like people that are
arrogant but I just did it just later I
call those people up as a joke well how
much you remember they go oh my God you
did tell us Spotify and I said yeah but
I tell you why oh my God why didn't you
tell me you [ __ ] I'm like because
it's to make you [ __ ] pay attention
to what I say isn't it funny when like I
think Joe Rogan tweeted something about
Jones being right I think was it the
Epstein stuff yeah and so it's like you
more you know you could tell them be
like you should have listened
but I don't it's my sixth sense of humor
I'm saying that but that reason I raised
that story is I kind of am mad at myself
because I've never bought stock why
didn't I do that but it's just I don't
think like because it was why didn't I
do it dark energy like you said like
corrupted tainted I think there's
something about purity or or honest I
just realized that is maybe not more I
don't this is a challenging conversation
Audrey anytime you exactly once you get
in that ocean you're in it I I have
nothing to do with it not because not
even some purist I just there's
something about the stock market it's so
it's so evil man I remember when I when
when like around this time and I learned
about this and I thought to myself like
wow that Stock's gonna Skyrocket and
then I just like carry down with my day
and like went and made a sandwich
on a show yesterday we talked about
library and their their crypto went up
200 yesterday yeah it's a baby
coincidence Hot Potato but you when you
talk like dude no look man you one thing
I really can't stand about the crypto
stuff is that someone will go on a high
profile show with a hundred thousand
viewers concurrent and be like this is
the coin Anyway come on you're telling
me that everyone shouldn't go and buy
ethereum right now that ethereum isn't a
great investment I think ethereum is
really the best place and it's a better
story of money than Bitcoin which is for
losers let me just say how this works
ethereum we all need new currencies we
all need blockchain these are real
Sciences we need new currencies we this
is a libertarian view to free up markets
and have our new systems to get out of
the central banks the problem is
everyone's pumping a bunch of BS to make
money on it going up at a pump and dump
and that's wrong and they want dollars
they don't want the crypto should pump
and dump be the name of that
pay-per-view Threesome that you have
perfect so listen listen oh my God this
is up and dump this is one of those Joe
Rogan Alex Jones and Tim Dillon the
ultimate gay orgy live the big problem
now that is an experience it's a big
problem that's the Joe Rogan I think
that's going to be on PornHub yeah I
don't know about that the big problem
with crypto is that if crypto is going
to be a viable currency outside of these
central banks or or the you know the
Fiat stuff people have to want it more
than they want the Fiat but they don't
they want to buy the crypto hoping that
the dollar yeah it's all pure
speculation it's not pure speculation
this has some functions but let me tell
you for some of it Max Kaiser you know
who he is right I don't well you know
Max he's always one of the original guys
he tried to give me like 20 million
dollars of it or whatever this is like
13 years ago at Bilderberg when it first
came out and when did it first come out
oh it was 2009 I think yeah 11 years ago
I never heard you know you know what
year
look
no I think it's to that point is I
didn't do it because I got it with
speculative it doesn't mean I don't
think it's not a real technology I'm not
going to lead my listeners to that no no
listen listen Bitcoin is a tremendously
valuable technology it's very very
simple if I want to transfer value from
here to say Japan no I get we need a
different system it's just it's like the
the normal system like if if you want to
give someone in Europe if I want to hire
someone in Europe and and pay them to do
art right so I hired some European
Studio to do the animation for my video
from the music video I did then it's
it's not particularly easy to transfer
money from me to them by the way that
was a good video no thank you but but uh
Chris got a band that night we played it
crypto uh is instant so I can give me
your address boom you've got it you file
your paperwork in your country you deal
with your taxes I agree and everyone
that's doing it I agree should trade in
it but listen listen the the the current
price of Bitcoin is meaningless if I
take 200 and buy Bitcoin and then
transfer it immediately to you and say
Japan you sell it immediately for 200 no
that's the whole thing you don't sell it
you start using
people right now are using Bitcoin to
they'll go to someone and say I'll take
you know 100 Bitcoin send it to you and
you'll sell it for 100 that hundred
dollars transferred immediately and
there's intermediaries who make money
off holding and trading sure just like
stocks it's a trading Mexico by ethereum
The reason it's a simple way for me to
transfer value instantly to you and we
don't care about the coin but the
problem is a bunch of other uh uh s
coins s coins we already swore so I'll
just say it's [ __ ] coins and what they
do is most many of them do literally
nothing and they're Ponzi schemes
I've had major not to name drop it's
just weird major Hollywood stars call me
and go we'll pay you a million dollars a
week to promote this coin and then
I literally don't promote it in like a
month six months later they even died
the guy that owns the company I mean I'm
like whoa dude I'm not touching any of
this I mean that's what I'm telling you
the reason why ethereum is better than
Bitcoin is because of smart contracts
which is a new type of technology that
can be embedded in the coin so what you
can say is when this ethereum goes to
this person we're going to activate this
program so like I want my power turned
on this month instead of giving them a
dollar and hoping some human does it and
trusting that there's a human there when
the coin goes it automates the
transaction so that's the future of
cryptos I want to be clear all of this
is the future I love new currencies I
love it all I'm just saying just like
the gold rush into California or the oil
rush into Texas or Pennsylvania there's
always wildcatting and scams that go
with the boom yeah Michael and I'm just
saying do you think aliens use
cryptocurrency I'm just kidding I think
I think aliens have all sorts of
training systems mainly on raw material
and ideas and data I heard that Star
Trek is communism
well it is it's the U.N symbol when they
talk about the contract the
international Global Federation Star
Trek isn't communism start start I
didn't really mean to ignite this nerd
debate but it's not I wonder if they use
Electro lasers like they vaporize
materials and then shoot it with a laser
to a receptacle where they cool it down
back into the material aliens oh aliens
all right let's let's talk serious about
this but the aliens let's let's here's
the deal see we're trapped in this I'm
like Gilligan who played Gilligan on
Gilligan's Island I'll always be
Gilligan or J.R on Dallas clearly the
skipper or Darth Vader who are you
fooling well who would you you know you
know I was wondering I'm a Marianne type
guy I like Marianne yes she's the best
yeah does your family have any uh like
Famous Recipes or or foods that you are
proficient in producing caught my mother
when I was a kid I was totally spoiled
when I was around around three meals a
day five course dinners Gourmet cook uh
she doesn't cook that much she cooks
some now like one meal a day but my
mother I was I was brought up with a
classic mother that was just badass I
mean apple pie we're talking ironing my
shirts and loving it and like cooking
five-star meals you're very lucky and
everything else so yeah I know you
laughed when I asked a question it's
it's silly but it's it's meant to be as
as base basic as possible because like
you mentioned about being Gilligan
people have this image of you and you're
one thing and I'm like you've certainly
baked a cake before Alex you know what I
mean like you've certainly done right
yeah exactly gay frogs you've certainly
been a regular person doing regular
things we talked about this on the phone
the first time we were setting up the
show because I'd mentioned how crazy it
is that people like you're probably
going to the grocery store to buy milk
I'm a lot more than just Alex Jones Okay
frogs I have my husband Luke radowski
he's also gay lizards and gay Birds
I'm getting serious he's okay Doctor
Doolittle no but that's what they do is
there's probably five memes that have no
exaggeration 100 million views each you
know different things and it's all the
same like I'll eat my neighbors gay
frogs and then the gay neighbor thing I
said this is an allegory of like the
road Vigo Mortensen the collapse of
society if you really go down this
malthusian road we could be eating our
neighbors okay fine I'm gonna eat my
neighbors I'm sizing them up with a
chain I said before in the same
10-minute segment I said before and
after this is theater that's that's
that's that's what they do yeah like
they look for Clips to take out of
contacts to make a super cut Alex you're
also a performer you know you're a
performer you you act up in a service
yes I believe in my political views and
then they go oh but you admit you you're
an actor in movies like yeah I'm an
actor in that movie you know Scanner
Darkly or or you know uh oh yes I gotta
ask you my buddy played you in the hunt
did you watch that movie I did not oh
okay it's a good movie I thought it was
gonna be bad it's actually really funny
yeah uh did you guys know that I'm on
two episodes of a thousand ways to die
no yeah you guys know that show yeah I
was in uh I was in two I was in one
where a mime eats a pickle and then
chokes to death okay and they hired me
as skater dude and my line was sick and
I did the the Hang Ten thing and the
other one was I was a rapscallian punk
with my young female friend and we were
skateboarding and drinking 40s in a park
when a cop came up who was huffing paint
and then told us to leave and stole our
drinks and then dropped his gun and
picked it up backwards and killed
himself these are this is a TV show I've
never seen that yeah so so I'm in these
two episodes and it was funny because uh
I filmed them before Occupy Wall Street
my friend was a a a like an assistant
production assistant so she was like we
really need skater guy for these two
episodes so I went I was like I'll
definitely do it I got paid like nothing
it was like 50 bucks but then I went to
Occupy Wall Street where I actually met
me this guy lukeowski I get a bunch of
press attention but it didn't air until
like a year after we filmed it and then
everyone started accusing me of using my
my fame from occupy to go to Hollywood
to try and be an actor actually I
remember hearing that no I heard reverse
he's CIA he's an actor he's a crisis
actor there's the proof yeah yeah what
me which by the way I barely ever talked
about crisis actor stuff like that might
get in the name of the thing they always
attacked so I don't want to coverage
they're like will you promise to stop
talking about this event I barely ever
talked about it I hate it I'm like
allergic to it but it's it's listeners
and it's random minority people to do it
but it's always the minority but they
can't they can't recognize faces so they
think on Beau Bridges they think I'm
Bill Hicks and they think everybody's a
crisis actor
look in that in that vein when you
mentioned Alex
oh my God Genghis Khan
you're a crisis actor you're really
Genghis Khan
you know herd is a it makes I am a
gorilla kill yourself Let's uh let's uh
let's let's let's let's I think I think
we have to actually just jump into
aliens yes we have to right it's never
gonna happen well they're real I mean I
can't prove that
it feels like it
stop stop stop stop stop right now
I am a guru
Let's Get Serious I am going to prove
aliens are real in the next five minutes
you guys go ahead and talk and then I'm
gonna prove aliens are real and are on
the planet and the new ones are being
made every day get ready all right
what's your favorite band Michael uh
probably Blondie is it really yeah
they're pretty good yeah yeah oh that
was like late 70s call me yeah part of
glass I've met Debbie a few times and
she wasn't nice but that's okay really
oh that's a bummer that's all right I
really like Muse Muse is pretty good
Muse is awesome they're more
contemporary yeah modern yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's true yeah yeah that's why I got
like what's your favorite what kind of
music do you like Alex do you think you
think I have enough big black bodyguards
up here
I'd say so I thought it was one of those
weird like church choirs behind you yeah
no it actually has a bunch of security
guards here it's not joking security
yeah no so so so we've talked about it
um we've had some some light light
chatter here's the problem you don't
tell them no but I said these are great
people great great people
the thing is I will need them tomorrow
with antifa this big rally nice they
will try to attack us so they're not
lazy like hey you guys take the night
off after dinner no we're going with you
so they're they're good guys they're
great people and then we definitely need
them you know antifa attacked everybody
three weeks ago after our big March like
five million people they were like
beating up women and children so the
only these guys tomorrow they're gonna
be earning their money tomorrow but
they're definitely I kind of guilty I
got these huge dudes did you cut on like
10 people did you come in heavy oh
[Laughter]
sure I'm gonna lay on you I'm gonna lay
on
some [ __ ] literally is this time oh my
gosh
[Laughter]
I mean I don't want you okay I want
lucrative have you guys ever studied I
just shall have him well no no he's got
to prove aliens exist you think about
the climatics
aliens exist
Luke is our son
Princess Leia I'm Darth Vader Luke
Luke is your son I've been saying that
what is happening
he's our son so the Israeli uh foreign
ER
you know what that means look who's your
son
I have to kiss Luke no it means he likes
killing children
yeah it's a Sith younglings
uh Israeli former head yeah see you're
the one who told me you were like I'm
getting pigeonholed I'm Gilligan I want
to talk about space program I'm like
okay okay I really want to just make gay
jokes jokes
the former head of the Israeli security
Space Program Federation
I'm no longer a gorilla
all right sorry stop stop all right
let's get serious
it's serious as me bringing a bunch of
huge security dudes to your house what's
the point of that it's fun I thought it
was I was I was like that's kind of
interesting we're in the middle of
nowhere are you worried about me I want
to intimidate you okay wait maybe I
thought you were intimidated no they I
am scared no no they're just they're
professionals yeah man I need protection
from Tim Poole that's true do people
don't know the Tim pool can like pull
your heart out with Jiu Jitsu and
concept like you've heard a lot of stuff
I think he's more Tech I actually took
uh uh Kung Fu oh okay yeah yeah there
you go all right let me guess let me get
serious yes I'm gonna prove to you
aliens right now all right let's do it
you wanna hear this yep yes
alien simply means not of this world or
new correct okay
hold on a little you want to debate that
Mr malice no but I feel like if you're
gonna do linguistic Jiu Jitsu this is
not going where we thought we was going
to go are you
are the Grays real are you in League
with lucredowski I am well we are in one
League Luke's not even saying anything
you keep pulling him into that I think
we're ready to have him mignon
all right well let me let me get serious
I am a gorilla murder yourself
with 10 minutes of you saying this it's
gonna be 40. no no that'll be a fact
check
the show is banned he's not a gorilla
he's not actually he's not supposed to
have fun with you [ __ ] and big Tech
but listen let me get serious
I will prove to you aliens right now
okay let's let's cover it right now
you know they have the theories that
humans came from being seated here on
Earth yeah they establishing the New
York Times as our Pan's pan spermium yes
whatever it's called yeah but these are
like regular scientific theories that
like fungus came down and like crashed
on Earth through meteorites and the
reason is it kind of violates the laws
of entropy like you don't have any
simple system that spontaneously becomes
more complex it's always the complex
systems break down so something's not
yeah and and to add to that life is a
negative entropy insofar as it creates
more entropy as life is created you know
so so there's always more entropy being
created continue good sir no exactly so
so
obviously like the mainline Baptist
preacher doesn't get it but he goes I
didn't come from a monkey and you don't
find a Swiss watch out in the middle of
Sahara Desert well but that's actually
true but it doesn't mean his six
thousand year old models are right you
know that's BS and it doesn't mean like
they're claim that oh 50 million years
ago this happened they don't know
there's actually jumps in evolution yeah
and that's what we know like something's
going on here Evolution's real and all
of a sudden totally like you know it's
called the Cambrian explosion right like
where we have this fossil layer of all
of these different species that emerged
around the same time yeah over and over
again so let's talk about that first
then I'll give you the alien proof
general public just thinks I make this
up you guys know it each step you know
the next step I'll give you the next
step after that yeah the Cambrian
explosion I don't know how do we
Leverage The shale's another one yeah
yeah basically like Evolution does not
it's not happen at a uh uh single rate
it has these weird spikes and it's not
at all clear what would cause these
spikes to occur and like the formation
of the the solar system happened in one
moment it looks like in three and now
they know matters going both directions
big Bang's not true there's a bunch of
bangs going on like popcorn yeah
interesting so
um one thing I I went and saw this uh uh
lecture from this scientist guy he said
he took it to a religious place which I
didn't didn't agree with but he talked
about it that's right you are he talked
about the astronomical odds by which we
exist on Earth and he said something
like what you need to realize is that
Jupiter is a filtration system for the
solar system keeping away the asteroid
belts all the Comets all the exactly
yeah and stops them from hitting us and
the moon's at the perfect spot for us
we're like the perfect spot this is such
a logical fallacy Are you seriously
going down this road well you'll argue
out of billions of star systems
took it to a religious place I don't
agree with no I'm saying it's not that
Earth is special it's not we're here
no no no stop don't I don't want you to
misinterpret me do you know the the the
the I don't know what you call the
allegory of the puddle there's a puddle
of water and it looks around and says I
fit perfectly in this hole in the right
because this puddle this hole was made
for me right I did it just because we're
in this very special position doesn't
mean it's it is special because there's
so much stuff especially because we're
here it's not that we're here because
the point I was making is that there was
a guy who was giving the speech to me
talking about how the position of
Jupiter the position of the Moon all of
these things are so astronomical it must
prove oh that's it's and I said that's
the exactly no it's the option no this
is where the environment exists to let
it happen yeah exactly if it wasn't for
Jupiter life couldn't have emerged here
right and but and nothing else yeah
interesting theory about how they got
formed apparently a long time ago either
it was a binary star system that
collided and then because of a z pinch
it just ejected all this matter into
what we now know as a solar system 24
Rocky bodies of planets all colliding
into each other Giant Gas bubble like
Saturn still has um a heat signature
inside it like it's an old star and it
was either from a binary Collision yeah
that's the whole 2001 detonating Lucifer
is supposed to be Saturn I think they do
Jupiter in the movie but but yeah that's
detonating Lucifer's reignite that star
all right so let's what's the next step
Alex the aliens
um
okay well let's just say it you're like
of course we know that once I say it
the globalists have said we know there's
jumps in evolution we're going to
artificially take control of human
evolution and so when they take
different
families of bacteria and and plants and
animals and mix them and create chimeras
which have been going on for more than
50 years it's all admitted down lichen
is an example of this like that's a
natural Chimera yes and and like a
jellyfish is also a oh what's that a
siphonophore
man of war that's right yeah it's like
four different things matched together
correct crazy that's a colony creature
yes yeah wow yeah so the globalists are
all into this and that's what they're
obsessed with but so they want to make a
human centipede three people I could
suggest look a big knowledge there's
interdimensional
Colony creatures and we're only one
level of a colony creature and that's
what the globalists actually believe
this is like the highest level stuff
this is what I was talking about with
the elves Hardware 3D manifestations of
4D being right but here's the next thing
so they're all creating you could say
well if you take fungus and a plant and
a bug and mix it together you can still
say it's off the Earth so it's not alien
but with nanotech and with crispr
editing they are now creating
with computers and thousands of labs
pure research scrambling genetics
together
and making new creatures which are alien
and have never existed on this planet so
we're building the aliens here now
that's fact aliens are here we're
building them and you can say we're like
a dimensional super intelligence gate
that can't help but create and like like
Atlantis whether Atlantis are those
aliens of those artificial life forms
they are they're artificial life forms
but I don't know if you can call them by
the definition they're made by man
listen here's the deal by the definition
is it's never been on the planet it's
totally new and it's mathematically
created oh have you seen artificial have
you seen the glowing mice
but that's like very rudimentary based
on what you're saying by the way they've
made myself did you know the new the big
vaccine that just got approved in
England the Pfizer vaccine has jellyfish
genes in it what but that you could go
to any Petco and have a glow-in-the-dark
tetras with Chef jellyfish facts uh
jeans I know that's what I'm telling you
yeah
East Texas
they bought it for the Mexicans okay
we're one of the only ranches now no
seriously we bought it from Mexico like
they said we bought it from the Mexicans
no it's just we bought for the Mexicans
I'm saying it's that long see how like
under political records he was saying we
bought it from the Germans we bought it
from the Russians we bought the Japanese
I bought it from the Mexicans sounds bad
see how we were like self noting
you bigot you have to go back some
Mexicans we've got an Old Ranch okay
we've got an Old Ranch and we the where
is your sombrero
actually cowboy hats are from that's
true he's right we're from Spain to
Mexico and actually the whole we think
of Western stuff it's like an Anglo
thing that's actually Hispanic and the
pedal steel guitar came from Hawaii
a lot of it yeah well the banjo came
from uh your guitar came from Spain yeah
wow but but what I'm getting at here is
is that
most the ranches around us because we
kind of got regular just beef cows not
fancy enough to pay the taxes but now
20 years ago they were doing artificial
insemination 40 years ago all that now
almost all the ranches around us are
clone cows is that right oh no way yeah
no no that was illegal no one I'm
telling you it's already Main Line dude
the Bulls are cloned
then they artificially inseminate create
clones the biggest cows I thought colony
was illegal wait if it's artificial
insemination that's not cloning no no
I'm saying 40 years ago they were doing
artificial oh okay I've done artificial
insemination if you have sex with Tim
Dillon that's I guess it's artificial no
when I was a kid they used to send me
when I was like 10 and 11 12 to work at
this time Alex Jones is 100 correct oh
snap uh clone Farms have been around for
some time apparently who knew what is
this
my family's in the beef business okay
and I'm telling you that 20. you're like
one of the only ranches in the area that
doesn't have clone cows dude the Futures
already here is what I'm saying that was
10 years 11 years ago I didn't I didn't
know that do you think that we're like
committing uh genetic modification in
order to easily connect with external
forces I'll tell you what happens
these big corporations dude I'm sorry
I'm sorry I just want to read this yeah
you know what validate what else to say
the U.S Food and Drug Administration in
2008 approved the sale of food from
clones and their offspring stating the
products are indistinguishable from that
of their non-clone counterparts twins
are clones Japan the European Union and
others followed suit the moves have
started controversy about whether
tinkering with nature is safe or even
ethical prompting major food companies
to swear off food products from cloned
animals but no one yeah but the thing is
twins are clones twins are natural
numbers let me give you the big news let
me get the big news
what I'm telling you is we know the big
ranches we sold them one of the biggest
ranges we sold them 10 000 Acres like
you know in the 60s it's clones now dude
and here's the crazy part
then you'll have clones breeding with
clones that aren't even made in a
laboratory but what you do is and I used
to work there but I don't understand
Alex if two clones breed then the new
Offspring is going to have new genes
right not close yeah that's what I'm
saying that's a hybrid right a clone
spring but let me tell you listen
I'm I'm nine years old the first time
that I that I that my dad goes you're
going for a month this summer to work at
this big famous Ranch I'll leave it
there it takes by our Ranch my Ranch is
small compared to this I go in there's a
guy looks like Santa Claus he's a vet
famous vet you got shipped off at nine
years old to work at a ranch yeah just
during the summer okay but let me tell
you for a story I come in this guy's got
a Santa Claus beard looks like Santa
Claus he's drinking whiskey at seven a.m
in the morning and it's a huge white
Laboratory
with squeeze shoots and all these cows
these giant black angus cows and he goes
watch this and they start running them
in he's artificially inseminating him
he's palpating him to see what's going
on he's explained to me genetic
engineering I'm like well I'm here oh I
like your dad that's why I get to say
this
so I meet the guy later he's working for
another Ranch
at the point was just all going on and
then I was there when the cloned animal
started coming in 30 years ago what what
what Alex what we need to stress is from
this article it's not just cloning it's
genetically modified animals okay I
checked this yeah they're not all just
clones exactly check this quote out this
is from reuters.com I want everyone to
look at this and I want to show you the
news guard certification that's
Microsoft okay boom 95 out of 100. you
know it's legit it's Royal Bill Gates
said so it's true quote if you don't
need as much corn to feed your cattle
you might be able to cut back on the
amount of fertilizer put out there on
the countryside that might end up in a
river you can cut the amount of diesel
that's been raising that corn just like
they improve the genetics of corn so
they can produce more bushels per acre
we're trying to do that same type of
thing by cause by using cloning and
Superior genetics to produce more meat
with less input and so but the point is
the banks just give you the money here's
what happens if you do the cloning they
just they leave you alone well here's an
example I can go to a ranch with all the
whitetail deer I want and do whatever I
want any time of the year because I know
the people of the state and they've got
these huge 12 000 acre ranches and stuff
it's all a ruling class man it's all
genetic Engineers it's all scientists
it's all a joke and and my dad got led
into it he was like 13 14 years old and
then and I'm telling you man it's a
whole super scientist deal like I only
saw like the first levels of it 15 years
ago Kevin Booth and I'll just go ahead
and say his name talk about Bill Hicks
he was Bill hicks's producer he got me
into the UT psychology department and I
was like why are they they want you to
be here and I went into the YouTube
psychology department there was this guy
that later went on to work for MIT high
level I didn't realize it was a major
CIA operator he goes hey let me just
show you all the secret DARPA stuff and
they were so smart they knew what I was
probably going to do in the future with
a trajectory and they were like and
Kevin didn't even know what they were
showing us it was like DARPA programs
and mind control programs in monkey
farms and all this stuff stuff like a
five hour tour of the classified area of
UT
and I'm saying is this is I was low
level imagine what you get when you're
higher level yeah my dad
at 15 was like Thomas class and he
volunteered for this uh science program
with NASA oh here we go here's the
backstory of Alex Jones no no this is a
true story well you call it MK Ultra
what do you want to call it but you know
whatever he was involved in oh this is
real stuff here here's the blue puzzle
piece falling into place this is the
blue puzzle piece yes sir
puzzle piece
no but it wasn't that special they were
getting all the best kids
who wanted a back of their cereal box
joined NASA so my dad's like 14 he
writes off to it I I want to do this
Nixon 18 wheeler shows up from Union
Carbide with a ruby laser design and
they say okay kid build this laser my
dad builds it writes a report they
hiring and now he's an MD Anderson
Cancer Research your dad built a laser
at age 15. yeah Ruby laser what was your
dad's name David Jones how did he know
how to build a laser at age 15 that's
amazing oh they sent him the blueprints
oh okay so it's like Ikea almost like
it's really dumb like well no it was a
test so the 18-wheeler shows up okay and
then like his mom was a big scholar and
also at the point is 18 wheeler shows up
at the farm no Eisenhower had funded
this okay he was out of he just left
office but it was it was an Eisenhower
program so my dad wrote off reported
NASA and so he went did some stains and
went and gave some got tested and stuff
and next it was like let's see what you
do with an 18-wheeler and a laser design
oh so he builds this Ruby laser and the
next thing they go okay won't you go
work at MD Anderson you're out of high
school he's at 15 but you're out of high
school kid he's in MD Anderson my dad
told me it was in a cancer research
people with no mandibles okay huge he
didn't tell me a lot of this when I got
older total secret research stuff
and then by
16 he said plan two UT they go let's
show you the secret reactor under the
building
they take him out of their secret
nuclear reactors
CD-ROMs computers flat screen TVs my dad
didn't tell me all this until 2007. okay
I already knew all this and finally he
leveled up with me and told me about
this whole secret government program all
the rest of it but that that's true
story and it gets crazier than that I
remember being at the table when I was
10 years old in Dallas and they're
trying to hire my dad and all the top
dental implant doctors in in Dallas they
were hiring as friends okay they were
hiring his friends because my dad had
been involved with some of those groups
and things and my dad did like the
dental work for the CIA because they had
like what they do for how little CIA
guys have guys in the room and all that
he did to Delaware for the CIA
this is ultra and so they're doing all
this work and uh
they want him to come to Maryland to
cite art I remember my mom's sitting
there going David I don't want 500 000 a
year and I'm not going to have you a
month in two weeks out in an underground
Base in Maryland my dad's like well it's
important cybernetic cyborg stuff and
it's for the country it's to stop the
Russians we got to do it my mom said I'm
going to divorce you my mother was never
like to she goes we're not moving to
Maryland in fact she goes I want to go
to Austin I'll be with my mother I'm
sick of Dallas and I'm sick of these
people we are not moving to America
and so I'm hearing my dad at 10 talking
about cyborgs man and that Dad never
didn't even join the program he wasn't
even in this stuff he just got recruited
on the outside of it got out of it but
because he was in that oh uh here's the
CIA deputy director you're going to be
his dentist now and you know I mean so
this is the type of stuff that goes on
it's how the system that wants you it
gets you my dad's gonna he probably
won't get mad because how do we go from
one of them on the show owned animals
too bring them on the show next time
because his dad was involved in the
sentiment H9 to the ranch
check this out check this out this is
from just this is us no but it's a
scientific Elite he was just low level
this is a scientific Elite and Gates and
fauci in them are in the elite my dad
just got recruited low level never got
into it because he didn't believe in war
my dad was like by the time he was at UT
in like 18. he's like I'm done I'm up
for war I'm not for all this let me get
out of it that's what I'm telling you is
is that is that this is how it all works
let me read this this is really
interesting in 2015 the Chinese company
Boyle life announced that in partnership
with the Korean company
biotech they were planning to build a
factory in Tianjin China to produce 100
000 cloned cattle per year starting in
2016 to supply China's growing market
for Quality beef look up their super
pigs that look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger that was from yeah that's
family guy wasn't it no it's real
Chinese super clone picks they have a
mutation called the myostatin deficiency
so if it's a double myostatin deficiency
they're gonna lose they're gonna develop
muscle at a very high rate there's also
a Whippet dog that has it and and these
Bulls yeah they look like bodybuilders
yeah so this is what you get when you uh
when you when you when you go to
Bloomberg not hey that's our new vice
president this is Bloomberg this is
absolutely News Guard approved this is
China's mutant pigs could save the
nation from pork apocalypse see They're
Gonna Save Us yeah they're talking about
the the gene research genetically
engineered pigs and Bloomberg made this
wonderful animation of this doofy
looking Pig flying around with the case
let me tell you the last story about my
dad
so he's 18. they wait till you're 18.
and he'd already volunteered for Vietnam
and they said no you're not going to
Vietnam we got something else for you
and the head of the UT body department
calls my dad in my dad known him for
like four years
and he says David you and these other
five people are the best in the state
and we're eugenicists we're going to
bring in World Government we're going to
depopulate the planet we're not like the
Nazis we're gonna talk at certain races
we're talking everybody that's dumb and
my dad was actually giving that speech
by the head of the UT body department
when was it that I have to ask this
about 1967. if your dad told you this in
confidence right how would he feel that
you're saying this publicly he knows now
okay I mean they already
yes well I had an uncle uh
I'll leave with that this is like you
had an uncle once go ahead so uh I want
to hear the rest of this I thought it
was done when I had an uncle that was a
highly decorated Vietnam pilot he had
six silver stars clandestine operations
in uh
in Laos in Cambodia he's one of the best
helicopters I ever had helicopter Pilots
and then he got recruited and I ran
Contra and he was a leader in that and
he and he saw some bad stuff got out of
it and then that's the rest of the thing
so I mean that's not that big a deal
that's like Industrial Level like Texas
is like where they get most of muscle
like whatever reason like it's heavily
recruited the point is if this is
something he didn't tell you so it's
2006 obviously it was a big deal to him
to keep it quiet for a few thousand
seven two thousand sorry I'm at my
office and I've got in game which is I
think my best film and I'm sitting there
watching it we're going to a ballet
reception for my first daughter and
she's like 17 now I got time plus and
my mom and dad come in we're about to go
to the reception in an hour and I've got
on a big screen TV the end of end game
about globalism world government
depopulation and quotes my mother looks
at my dad and she goes David this isn't
true is it and he goes yeah it is
actually true so I knew about some of
this stuff okay and then we get in the
car to drive to the to the ballet
reception and my dad goes yeah it's all
true they brought me in the room they
told me all this it's all true I was
part of this program he goes it's not
being Bob to other people in the program
point is they get everybody in the
program dude it's not like he was
somebody special anybody that was high
IQ at the top of the chart they
recruited let me ask you this do you
have any insight as to what really is
there some something we're not told
about about how the Cold War ended
because the Cold War was the best gift
to the military complex ever they can
spend infinite money every year it's
like the Russian yeah the Russians got
sick of it and figured out fighting them
made us stronger not them and they gave
up okay because they knew that we'd put
the Bolshevik set in 1917. they knew the
left had taken over and they were sick
of it and there was a secret rebellion
of Orthodox Christians and the CIA had
used Christians to infiltrate Russia but
the program went too well
and so Christianity into the Cold War
not blue jeans and not miller-like okay
huh didn't Gorbachev do a pizza
commercial
yeah perestroika
they'd already collapsed the the
Russians
90 of the Russians weren't buying into
it oh that's definitely true yeah it had
fallen and then Bush senior and them
were trying to prop up Yeltsin to act
like oh there's been a revolution
perestroika
Poland had pulled out Eastern Europe had
left Russia and so it had failed already
they were looking for an exit that was
uh not as embarrassing okay and and so
that was perestroika and Yeltsin uh you
know came after that and then Putin Lou
gardawski's father uh you know came came
after that you see a tough father-in-law
he is he is look get over here right now
I know I've been watching
take over for me for a few minutes
stalking me
so we need to we need to expand the
studio we've been we've been working on
it we got some new stuff coming in
nobody want to have more uh you got a
beautiful Studio well if we want to get
there's one rule though you said bang
the table bang it as hard as you don't
bang the table don't kick it that's the
only real rule because people just like
get carried away not slam the table no
all right
what's what's what's uh what would you
say is like the biggest or like the most
important uh uh secret and uh let me let
me rephrase this though but like we're
talking about these CIA programs we're
talking about the Cold War and all this
stuff and then even potentially aliens
and interdimensional stuff and fourth
dimensional projections where does it
all come together like what's going on
well let's talk about that
when I talk about interdimensional
information that's in the Sanskrit
that's in the Babylonians that's in the
all the ancient cultures said there are
these creatures that come to The Ether
and manifest on our side like like the
Gin the Gin exactly in Arabic lore
but when you get to the globalists Skull
and Bones is they're in coffins they are
taking drugs they are hallucinating in a
German Death cult that's thousands years
old in Germany and and says In 1832 in
in in New Haven Connecticut they take
this very seriously so I was at Bohemian
Grove it's not into that I'm like this
is stupid this is just some type of
Faustian deal but I was there with over
a thousand men during this hour-long
ritual they were like raptured I went to
Pentecostal churches when I was a kid I
went to baptist churches I've never seen
people so raptured and so obsessed so I
just wanted to I want to ask you because
you know when you were on Rogan I think
not the last like maybe two times ago or
the big one you did on YouTube where you
talked about the interdimensional aliens
in 5G or whatever and and hybrids
how does that tie into Cold War military
funding
well you know General stubblemine
was added you have special operations
and then after that he was ahead of
basically all
Army operations
and I interviewed stubble mind probably
10 times before he died
uh it was like a three-star General
four-star general I forget and uh he
couldn't release classified info
but he he basically they made men who
start goats about him but that's a white
watchpower really happened
and
they admit even in John Ronson's book
which is a whitewash that they killed
gods for their brains they were doing it
on a routine basis with their brains
they would stare together like a
two-year-old health is that what that
movie's about yeah yeah it's all a big
whitewashed but they would kill ghosts
wait it's like The Men Who Stare at
Goats that movie is about like psychic
people killing notes or whatever yeah
but they make a joke out of it right
kind of like you take a video of me
shooting somebody in the head with a 45
and blowing their brains out they they
show a video of me shoot my squirt gun
they make a joke about it
but they 100 percent
the Russians by the end of the Cold War
were like spending half their budget on
the stuff because they'd seen results
and and of course there's all these
Carnival markers and Gypsy scammers and
whatever you know Pentecostal scammers
that are out there doing stuff but
there's there's a real power you know
the there's a real other dimension to
the thought processes and so that's what
I'm talking about is that is that
this has been studied this has been
looked at this is what's going on and
this is what the establishment let me
tell you you guys are pretty prominent
reporters but you know a lot of people I
know a lot of billionaires particular a
lot of rich women billionaire like
heiresses and stuff all they're doing
all day is occultic stuff and religious
stuff and psychic stuff this is the
whole world like a David Rockefeller or
a Bill Gates level he says he's doing
science but let me tell you behind the
scenes it's all a cult it's all hidden
they're all trying to figure out that
super Factor because they realize that
the brain is picking up all this other
stuff and they want to understand that
because it's that magic ingredient that
is the ether is DMT the secret to
getting that information you know I've
now taken DMT uh but when you have low
oxygen dreams it's released yes and if
you in a few other things it's released
so I have DMT type dreams all the time
and absolutely I think that
if you're already a loser and already
had a bad life and never had good
experiences and not saying you're a
loser but you're a loser because you
never had good experiences DMT or
anything is going to exacerbate it make
it worse but if you are really dialed
into things and and really touching in
the universe it's going to accelerate
everything a thousand times and really
tear the tear the veil aside and that's
the key
I remember this is the Clockwork Health
story and this is my parents are this is
like standard stuff known in the
intelligency it's not like my parents
were that special my mom had a friend
who lived in San Francisco who was
involved in a big International
psychedelic Institute which is really a
government funding program through the
university there at Berkeley and several
others
and I remember at the dinner table and I
was like seven eight nine hearing this
and then my mom went to Arkansas once on
a road trip and I'm in the back of the
Volkswagen Beetle listening to this
woman who was involved in these projects
told my mother about yeah we're trying
to map it and there's these elves and
there's these other groups and and you
know we're doing it intravenously and
she's talking about DMT she wasn't
calling it DMT but she's talking about
like astronauts trying to map all this
and I was I was on Rogan two years ago a
few months later I had a professor on
going actually we're starting Charles
universities with a ravenous trip it's
like once I said that then it was like
okay Jones already released it nothing
Roga was involved they went ahead and
you know talked about it and so and this
woman was involved in all this stuff
okay and so I'm here listening about The
Clockwork elves and Terence McKenna and
uh Timothy Leary and their projects and
the FBI and the CIA and my mom was not
involved in this she's talking to this
woman it was one of her best friends and
she's she's hearing all of this and I'm
driving up to Arkansas you know four-day
trip with them you just stay at the
Arlington or whatever in Hot Springs and
I'm listening these women talk about
like these astronauts and how they're
going to another dimension and how
they're mapping it and how they'll have
like 10 of these the term they used was
like explorers and they're all seeing
the same thing yeah and that's why they
knew this is real because they're not
all having some group hallucination
they're all in hospital beds doing this
going and seeing the stuff and trying to
map it and the problem is like a 50
second or a minute long Trip's not
enough so these people are signing on
and they went further that dealers for
my family I did research
I've been like flatliners or something
in the 80s they have people that have
their hearts turned off because they
found turning the heart off is even more
to go deeper into this and so then they
pump the blood through a machine and
these people actually go into death to
have near-death experiences and to be
sent into these dimensions and
communicate and then that's what you
learn about the satanists other occult
groups and the the Aztecs and others
were doing sacrifices to like these
entities want blood they want energy
they want that sacrifice and then they
come and then they give you data like
you read the old Grand Wars Black Magic
books and it's all you sacrifice a child
then the demon appears and then you ask
it where's buried treasure or how do
things political enemy they're asking
dumb questions well now it's like how do
I create the Ultimate Weapon well here's
the equation the atomic bomb and then
you learn like uh what's his name um how
do these in in demons and dimensional
beings have this information well here's
an example I'm sitting there like 30
years ago watching Access TV in Austin
there was some preacher I forget his
name who's only on Austin on Access TV
he's got all the books of uh I found
that guy he's got all the books like
some nerd dude he's super smart all the
books of uh
Charles Darwin and I'm like wait I
remember reading I mean I've read the
theory of species or whatever it is
I know about Charles Darwin he has all
these books so I was so crazy what he
said there was no internet then really I
went to the library they didn't have
they said go to UT I went and I found
a scan in their microfilm of this book
from like 1880 or whatever of Charles
Darwin where he had an hallucination in
South America and these entities through
the veil told him how it all happened
and what was going to happen and what he
should do and here's this preacher
saying demons took him over and they
told him how to do it he called him
aliens but they weren't and they told
him how it all worked and then I didn't
believe it it was like this if it's
Charles Darwin was in communication with
aliens I want to know this I went to the
library and found the book he wrote
talking about the hallucinations he had
where the demons told him this I mean
he's like isn't uh all this infinitely
more interesting than current events yes
absolutely I am trapped by Trump and I
have nothing against Trump I'm not like
oh wimp now turning against Trump it's
the opposite I just I'm sick of it
because only talk about Trump only talk
about the Texas cases it's so
one-dimensional and now it's like you
know where it takes that as a sort of
pun you know we're talking about I guess
bigger questions about the universe and
the what I find Most Fascinating about
uh uh oh my he's I'm validating with
Alex said I'm going to interrupt you
yeah Charles Darwin had something that
they think is called Charles Bonnet
syndrome a condition where visual
hallucinations occur wow so what you're
saying is that he was actually seeing he
could see through the veil I
don't know I was watching a pressure at
like 18
. remember his perfect set his Pace
everything looks like this little nerd
dark dark hair but he would like he was
on every day on access and he had all
these books he's like and Charles Darwin
was having hallucinations with aliens
they were demons and I'm like this is BS
so I finally went down and met the dude
he was showing me some of the stuff
that's another story
and then I went to his church and then
the main preacher had a heart attack it
was weird I love the church but along
with her a couple times but the point
was I went down to UT once I found the
name of the book I mean I went down
there I'm like Charles Darwin was having
Communications with what he believed
were off-world entities that's what
Darwin thought so I went to see it and
read it for myself and I said why was I
never told this this is insane
I mean you know whether he was crazy or
not the whole Foundation of our whole
system is based on this and no one's
telling you Charles Darwin had a hundred
and fifth whatever it was 110 fever and
a three-day hallucination and and like
communicated with the aliens
the interdimensional beings that's same
so so that same preacher so when we talk
same preacher had New York Times
articles that I can't find
of a major rock band in New York
sacrificing a young boy and then he was
and then I went and looked it up and
couldn't find it so you know maybe no
he's not real but he had the the Charles
Darwin thing turned out bro and some
things could be true I don't know maybe
he was like here's you know but I'm just
saying there's been a lot of crazy I
used to think that information was
passed by light and that we're receiving
it into our brains you know
electromagnetically but I'm wondering if
it's like a lower vibration a lower
frequency like Alpha Waves no they say
the elves say everything's music do they
really yeah what does that mean though
yeah it's all like it's like it's like
gong and clocks and bing bong ding yeah
and also that music and math music
affects both part of your brain right
because it's mathematical so it's got a
pattern to it but it's also the artistic
part of the brain so basically
um Christmas music is what it sounds
like I'm like I think they mean it
metaphorically so no but I'm telling you
that's what I'm it's like you're like
choral music and like like clocks
chiming I think that's what they but I
just mean as a metaphor in this sense
that's why they call it Clockwork elves
is that right is that where the term
comes from I never
I'm taking DMT to see it but that's what
they say Where's that machinos yeah it's
both but my understanding Clockwork
machine knows it's like you're in a
clock but it's belongings
but it's also that certain things happen
recurring in your life just like the
chorus to a song and you have the chorus
then you leave the chorus which is going
to be the through line of your life or
whatever and you're gonna have the verse
which your different things start
happening but then the whole background
time you're still going to be returning
to the chorus at a certain point so it's
kind of like if you visualize how a song
goes It goes here then it goes away then
it comes back then it goes it's like uh
like a sine wave what's the term
um we're reborn it's the yes the Eternal
rebirth yeah the cycle yeah so that's
kind of like what they mean by reality
being music reincarnation and they're
saying what does it matter if we die
we're a repeat again which is having a
new experience which adds to it it's
like a wheel rolling they're like why do
you care if you die it's going yeah
and also the point that like some songs
are longer than others that doesn't mean
they're better or worse than others have
you heard like a didgeridoo
all right yeah
oh he's right that's what that's what it
is that because the heart's beating so
you're getting these fluxes of blood
pressure causing I agree like when I'm
exercising in the morning not that look
like I do it a lot but I do I I [ __ ]
hike like 20 miles this week it's like
when I'm charging up a hill my brain's
the best because it's like
a minute it's second to Second you have
that half second of super intellect when
all the blood hits the cells you're like
oh I just I didn't say oh look at that
again yeah exactly so when you're on DMT
are you hearing like music when those
pulses come it's like a hyper intensity
I think DMT removes your normal
visual blinders that let you analyze
things so if you're a fighter pilot they
can't give you a thousand readouts you
got your main readouts and so it removes
all the readouts and you're just like
seeing like yeah
the full the full dashboard with with
all your senses which is just the sense
of touch all the senses are really just
extrapolations of touch vibration on on
receptacles so you have like yeah now
you're just a soul a spirit whatever it
is like experiencing now you're floating
around on air you're like what so what's
what's what's the meaning of life
it's whatever your song is you know in
math the music it is life is row row row
your boat gently down the stream merrily
merrily merrily merrily what's your
karaoke song that's the secret to the
universe
merrily merrily merrily merrily life is
better okay I think you tried say it
again what is your karaoke song
because you've got a very distinctive
voice and a very like kind of uh
you know I like Ace of Spades
but the only God
oh that one okay I can tell you what the
meaning of life is it's a verb meaning
is a verb in math when you take the mean
of a system you're taking the average so
when you mean life you're creating an
average to the system if it's too good
you're going to make it worse if it's
too bad you're going to make it better
I'm not always finding the center I know
the purpose of Leaning life
the simplest and most discernible
function of life is uh negative entropy
it's about it an equal and opposite
reaction to an extent I'll say this Mr
pool not not equal Mr malice I'm just
glad we did just transcend Trump another
against Trump but I'm not Trump so I
told Joe this I love Joe Rogan but I
went there and was like you know prove
me wrong to help me he's like I'm gonna
help you we're going to fact check you
and I'm like Oh my tooth's hurt but I
appreciate we've actually transcended
Trump now
which I want to transcend the sensors I
want to transcend all this dumb stuff I
care about liberals I care about
conservatives I hated George W bush I
used to try to get you on the show back
when you were doing you know Occupy Wall
Street and it's not that I'm groveling
to the left it's like I'm not who they
say I am so it's good to be able to come
on here and finally just move past this
kind of a real discussion it's because
Trump is like this small little part of
my life yeah and I'm but I had to like
let me let me let me tell you guys
something and I'm really interested what
you think about this Michael hold on I'm
going to show you something because
something just happened but go ahead
something just happened yes and I'll
show it to you you're gonna read this
that loud I'm gonna read it out loud is
it something huge it's a text message
from my buddy it's time stamped what
does this say
I need you to look at my calves here
read what that says from and the
timestamp
Friday 5 14 p.m that's earlier today I
love how everything is Flowing for you
Friday 5 15 p.m just Transcendence
everywhere
what about Trump's tweets because
what do you mean by that he just kept
talking let me
let me I want to say something about we
were talking about the meaning of life
in the in the in the creatures and the
elves and all that stuff you know so I I
was uh uh I was reading something a
really long time ago about uh entropy
and how life only exists like only
exists in creating complex systems so
long as it creates more entropy around
it and the one thing I realized because
I was reading this book about the the
expansion of complex and dynamic systems
or complex Dynamic systems life as like
as far as we can tell you never know
what you're gonna get well it keeps
every bit of it from the basic uh
self-replicating protein up to humans is
different degrees of creating more
complicated systems you have creatures
that replicate themselves turning free
energy into a complex system within
itself up to humans Who start creating
abstract Concepts which are complex
systems which don't even exist in
physical space turning energy into
patterns of thought we're creating
higher Dimensions I I feel like you just
glossed over something that's I'm
finding to be kind of a big deal the
Transcendence thing yeah which is he's
just going on and on about Transcendence
and just two hours ago and you have this
time stamp my friend was talking to me
about this Transcendence everywhere
what's your synchronicity there is there
is there is that's all I'm saying I
don't want to I don't want to get too
specific on what these numbers are
because it's personal information but
there are two specific numbers that
there's a series of numbers everybody
hasn't involved in their lives hi very
no I mean like everybody has your
personal numbers like phone numbers or
you know uh Social Security numbers that
keep coming up mine is no no well well
so just to be specific like you can say
you have a phone number you have a
birthday there are numbers in your life
something happened I mentioned this to
Michael two very specific numbers and a
very very weird way around the same time
colliding and you were like that's crazy
and I was I didn't say that's crazy you
said something like that right yeah no I
said this is the kind of stuff that I'm
talking about I was online I'm trying to
recognize that yes because then you're
like that it's like Matrix code I was
feeling the fact it's not crazy you're
doing it you're trying to understand the
universe and if you're not doing that
you're an idiot you'll notice when you
explain something to someone if they
don't understand you they think you're
crazy but they're the ones that can't
understand right if I start telling you
you should buy this the Spotify people
it's a perfect example Alex you're a
[ __ ] I'm not buying Spotify because
they're like I'm a stock person you're
just a jerk on a boat you get the sick
joke of it is they're already it wasn't
me being arrogant I was already Red Data
they were talking about stuff they were
being here acting arrogant so I joke I'm
on the well Joe Rogan for 10 minutes is
huge news so it's a joke I go hey you
guys go to my Spotify they laugh at me I
didn't even use the data because I'm not
part of that but it was like part of the
sick currency that God got the job
I'll tell you a story about a uh who who
brought Max Kaiser was it you brought it
Mexican so I was actually uh hanging out
with Max uh I know Maxie's cool dude and
and Stacy they're they're great people
and there was this billionaire guy they
knew and he was just like talking about
how he's gonna launch a newsletter and
he's like well you know I'm gonna give
people advice on what they should buy
and I said all right you're a
billionaire I'm broke what should I buy
and he said Square Jack dorsey's company
and I was like why is that and he goes
ease of transactions simple right
everyone's gonna start using this very
simple he's got the audience and it went
from so I I was broke I put a a small
amount of money into square at 13 bucks
it's at 215 today if you and if people
really want to be smart they'd be buying
ethereum
what you just said is key to him because
Beginnings are key you've got to make a
decision like a man and a woman together
or a business deal is this and you bet
at the beginnings where the money's
right the beginning and also ends but
and big changes but I mean it's just to
me the weirdest thing is I can I it
doesn't matter how successful I've been
doesn't matter if I've brought in you
know over the years we'll still even say
how much money it's a fun operation with
it but
it's weird like big globalist big people
listen to me but like average people
they don't listen they think when you're
giving them info like you're trying to
like embarrass them yeah they're like
they're like there's superstitious about
information no they take pride in dig in
their heels and not having you being
able to change their minds because they
think it's a battle of wills yeah
exactly so what is this thing listen
when I'm wrong about something I want to
learn about it yeah but you're a dad
right so I think I'm sure I don't know
your kids but like growing up a lot of
times you're like look I'm telling you
if you do a b and c this is the right
thing and they want they want to be like
oh your dad you're dumb I know it all
it's like all right don't listen to your
dumb Dad see what happens to you
yeah that's exactly what it is
probably because we're taught by
teachers our whole lives that are wrong
yeah a lot of times you're told to do
stuff that isn't right so when someone
comes along you know exactly you're
taught a lot of BS when I when I when I
was growing up I had my parents telling
me the truth and I had a dad who was
blunt and told me the truth I remember
adopted and it was a mistake when I was
when I was like seven I remember I had
to wake up school started at 7 30 in the
morning so I had to get up at 6 30 and
I'm waiting I'm all tired and I'm like I
don't want to go to school and my dad
goes don't go to school and I was like
what it's like don't go to school you
don't you can just choose not to and I
was like but I have to go to school and
he goes if you say so and I got up and I
went to school I made the choice but
that kind of thinking was what I was
brought up with challenging these norms
and these ideas and these authorities
and these systems and
I've I've always been questioning this
you know how people do things and the
rules and it's probably because of that
no that's true you know I've let my
children down because oh that's awful no
I've been good in a lot of ways but I I
wanted to be so loving and so good that
I just kind of let them do what they
want versus my parents said but I
thought I was like 13 they said get a
job you want to do close you want a car
go pay for it and I was thinking these
are hard asses but now I appreciated all
that it's the old story but it's true
and my kids are great but you give them
what everything they want they don't
appreciate it my kids are wonderful
they're wonderful but how many kids do
you have four oh wow okay we Thrive off
resistance that's like even trees need
resistance to grow well that's the old
confusion thing like the if the grass
isn't blowing it doesn't survive but is
there value to creating you know
imaginary resistance because that would
anger me if I was your kid and you were
like had all this money and I was like
why can't I have some you're like no go
do it yourself I'd be I'd get angry I'd
start to resent you so
I don't know maybe there is a value no
that's exactly right like my oldest
daughter's really smart good she goes
she goes you've got money why do I need
a job and I'm like do you understand
you'll be empowered by that if I just
give you money you're like a plant I
water yeah because it's also like what
if Dad gets mad and now he's got that
money he could hold his leverage over
your head what if I die right
not a stroke what
is someday take care of me yeah like I
take care of you you know it's like you
better learn how to do stuff it's gonna
be like baby I think there's a reason
why kids typically challenge the the you
know the adults it's a natural part of
evolutionary Evolution like it's like
three-year-olds is when they learn to
lie because that's when they're
realizing there's a disconnect between
facts and what my youngest daughter's
three and a half and she's just now
learned to like
if she doesn't want to like at the at
the store does it she wants a toy she'll
go help help like you know it's like
at least women man I'm telling you and
then someone walks over and sees a
little girl yelling help with Alex Jones
walking by and oh damn it's happening
yeah it's crazy man like it's it's
because you're right they're young lying
is creative it's like yeah and it's also
one way for them to be more powerful
than their parents yeah because they've
actually convinced the parents of
something that's not true that's real
power that's the only Power you have
that AJ my three and a half year old
Eric is my wife she can never talk about
her she's like we call her the Martian
ambassador I mean she's so damn smart
man she's like how does this operate
what is this thing I like this vehicle I
mean it's like I don't know what's going
on with children but it's they said like
there's these Indigo kids or these
Future Kids yeah yeah yeah they go Star
children yeah yeah everybody wants to
want to say their kids the best ever you
know but let me tell you we know adults
what is it you don't know about indigo
children I have a three and a half year
old that talks better than like a U.N
Ambassador you mean there's like
prodigies like super smart kids but they
also think they might have some kind of
uh like alien hybrid DNA I'm not kidding
that's a thing look at angular children
it's possible
it's possible that we're being seated
right now by fungal spores that we're
just not perceiving the manipulates our
genetics and manifest there you go yeah
everything else
pseudoscientific that's what the girl
yeah
Bill Gates says it's a lie so that's how
he knows the truth special unusual and
sometimes Supernatural obviously it's a
new age thing but if we want to believe
it it's our right like why do we have to
newscar red whether I believe in Indigo
because you're a guy telling people to
murder themselves
I had somebody on I was I was gassing my
car a few days ago and I walked over and
I go this looks like it's like a woman
she goes I'm a gorilla and like it looks
like a woman he's not sure what it was
looks like a woman well my point is is
that he's being politically correct come
on yeah it looks like this is
this is a Liz man
I had a dream about Max Kaiser and Stacy
earlier today talking about Synergy and
Max Kaiser who you brought up earlier
and who you just brought up in the dream
we were picking apples and I was driving
and whenever we would go through a tight
quarter Max would say good job I love
Max can you tell that somebody was
trying to explain to me I'm like I'm
like dude
a market investment
exterior my audience into something BS
and I'm not saying he's doing that I'm
just saying he holds a lot of Bitcoin
and he tells people to buy Bitcoins all
the time and he wants and now he says to
buy ethereum when he's when he says
exploding right now years and years ago
by Bitcoin I'm sure everybody wishes
they listened yeah man dude I was at
Bilderberg 2008 or whatever it was where
they make the teddy bears Build-A-Bear
[Laughter]
here's 10 000 Bitcoins and I'm like he
got really mad because I was like
drinking wine
and he can stay like I'm right now he's
like dude I just gave you ten thousand
that's the future and I'm like oh yeah
right that was that's right you were the
guy in the boat yeah and he was the Alex
Jones on the boat yeah that's how life
is a song yeah because it's the same
chorus with slightly twist wow there you
go and so I was asking myself I guess
you're not a dim fool after all I
figured it out Michael yeah when's the I
cracked the code when's the crescendo
where's the climax when's the big rising
action you know is this it like we're
getting all excited everything's going
crazy the states and then nothing
happens no skeet skeet what skeet ski
that that is that it yeah skeet skate
all right you busted
[Laughter]
we're gonna go to super chances like the
best thing that can happen it's just
calmness like if you think about the
best situations it's like a calm Farm
where the wind is blowing and it's peace
they say Valhalla it's like a high Farm
on a mountain that a plateau and
everything's happy and everything's
golden and you just love each other
that sounds good but then we create like
resistant we create problems to overcome
them to become stronger just in case
there's some cataclysm from outside the
system we send our children down the
hill into the valley for a war to make
demand wait before we go to super chats
I wanted to shout out the guy who makes
those Mammoth pens if you go to
foothillantiques.com
so you want this the pen yeah give it to
me hey hey Israel I'm having a great
time you're having a great job and we've
transcended Tim what are the other
topics we want to cover that we've moved
past can I give a plug to this
independent businessman who is suffering
because his business is down 60 who made
me a great pen and I'm giving it to Tim
only if he marries Joe Biden if you want
a Mammoth tooth pen check out Foothill
antiques on Instagram I've been given a
a pen it's from a real Mammoth yes
Mammoth Mueller and if someone throws
I'm a mammoth yeah so so so he he is
this is this this is not vegan though
let's get into real subjects let's talk
about the secret space program space
force and what you tried to do an hour
ago the Israeli former Heather Space
Program folks don't know Israel had the
fifth largest Space Program they put
satellites in space on saying that
there's an Intergalactic agreement
aliens are secretly experimenting I'm
not saying this this is mainstream news
fact check me oh great Bill Gates this
is big we should talk about that they
just renamed uh Kennedy's to the Trump
renamed a couple of like uh space
programs space launch pads to space
force now did you guys get that I did
Trump's doing a lot of things so we we
talked about this uh when it happened
but we have it from NBC News former
Israeli space security Chief says
extraterrestrials exist and Trump knows
about it a Galactic Federation has been
waiting for humans to reach a stage
where we will understand what space and
spaceships are see this is why someone
had some Lefty had a really funny tweet
about this they go the most unbelievable
part of the story is that Trump was able
to keep his mouth shut yeah and I'm like
you know what you're it it's it's not
it's it's not it but wasn't he asked
about it he said I'm gonna look really
hard into this
I don't I don't yeah he's like I'm gonna
take a good hard look into this UFO
thing I see Luke nodding over there he's
saying yes October
so maybe he just never really cared
maybe maybe he never I do not care about
aliens yeah come on by the way speaking
of trump we just became the gorilla
Channel which he was accused of watching
yeah I'm the gorilla Champion I have a
gorilla yeah that's this so that is
another example of synchronicity
it's just uh I mean if you look for
patterns you find them you know what I
mean here's what happened Trump what is
that she's shaking your head that assert
Trump ordered two years ago the JFK
files release and remember they wouldn't
do it he kept ordering it they released
a little bit it'd be like if my crew
didn't do what I want him to do I could
not do my show Tim if your crew didn't
like you you couldn't do anything be
honest you have to hire new people they
despise him yeah they hate me so much
well they love you but I'm saying is not
Lydia it's a hypothetical my point is
it's a hypothetical statement all I'm
saying is Trump orders all this release
they don't do what he says remember they
were going to have training which is now
happening
that all whites are racist and America's
bad tremendous and and Trump said stop
it I talked to a Green Beret two days
ago he was just shipped out to Utah to
be taught literally they make men wear
red high heels and they make them walk
around and say America sucks in a
brainwashing cult what
is that Alex got really drunk with Tim
Dillon no no no no no no that's just
really specific you know what I mean 100
000.
right now they made guys they made Green
Berets wear red high heels oh
emasculated and they learn how to give
[ __ ]
no no no you think I'm joking what's
your what's where does this come from
the mouth okay type in Army Soldiers
made to wear red high heels we gotta
look this up it's gonna pull up pornos
no no no no no I had a incredible
Patriot for America visit me he gave me
a little award he's right
and he said I said I'm out I can't do
this yeah I need to leave the earth I
need to pull it up pull it up pull it up
there you go Army to refute decision to
have male Cadets wear high heels what it
was part of Sexual Assault Awareness
Month they made the cadets wear high
heels
but currently they have been sent to
Utah these are like these guys are like
Green Berets super killers
and I said how is how is our buddy doing
and he said Alex it's literally dementia
make him quit they literally have red
high heels while in uniform as part of a
campaign called walk a mile in her shoes
wow Alex Jones was right he become very
vulnerable he also said teach them how
to give blow jobs
how do I pull this is a Washington Post
saying they're working I can't just
Google Army [ __ ] oh gosh guys wait
hold on it it came up it's from uh
PornHub that's where it came out all
right you guys laugh about us like no
I'm talking hold on let me let me just
let me just give you some credit we are
making fun of him when we literally he
literally just proved us wrong about the
high heels I was exposing the Super Bowl
four years ago in Houston running Super
Bowl Super Bowl like the football thing
yes okay in Houston running child
kidnapping Rings wait what not the Super
Bowl at the Super Bowl they had child
sex lives going on at the at the student
the NFL was involved at this no no at
the Super Bowl in Houston oh yeah they
were doing this I'm not saying the Super
Bowl did it okay
and so I had a guest on and all of a
sudden this guy comes from the US Army
and the CIA and he gets into my big
white board I know who he is he's a
well-known person he says Jones he's
really hit on somebody got to be careful
who's here who's involved here's he's
running it
and that's the same guy that told me
about all this I said where is this guy
when this other person visits me from
the government and he said well he's up
there being brainwashed in Utah right
now they're making him wear high heels
they're teaching them that it that that
that that they need to become
James Bond doesn't just have sex with
women so the point is is that they're
literally
I was told this so this is real I mean
that James Bond doesn't just listen
listen I think about the abuse of our
troops man they'll do anything for this
country and they're literally got them
in Utah wearing high heels and learning
how to suck dick well some of them
didn't have to learn oh it's true I mean
what the hell am I supposed to do here
is it possible that I'm allowed to
anecdotally tell you that that's the
kind of stuff they're showing them and
he's like why is the point it's meant to
run them off if they were women being
taught how to have sex with people it's
wrong what do they have men in a goddamn
base teaching them this war humiliated
oh it's a video of it humility they got
a video it's a video look at this okay
of the high heels not the other thing of
the high heels nothing obviously it goes
way worse than this through the Army to
conduct
let's Jump Ahead maybe if it plays Jesus
I don't think it's going to play they'll
probably ban that [ __ ] it's fake man
yeah this like what he brought a
building seven the feed's gonna go down
look at this look at this ROTC Cadets
walking a mile in there she was Army
ROTC there's nothing they're wearing red
high heels
what was that heels the largest Hills we
found red heels as high as we can get
them and walk 1.26 miles so we can
support them for that it's not as
Extreme as an imaginative
probably what I'm talking about you
can't run away dude I was talking to a
dude just like killed probably 200
people I said how are you doing well
we're being told to do this
they're being told
that's weird stuff you know they tell
men in the military hey we gotta
infiltrate get their women and we'll
treat their women we're telling guys for
America you need to learn to it's all
about just the most insane stuff you
ever heard what year is this from 2015.
yeah this is this is new I'm saying this
is five years ago yeah currently in Utah
they have special operations U.S army
wearing high heels wearing dresses
and and literally like they're like you
need to learn to not be upset by this
watch this porn here's how a [ __ ] is
conducted and the troops are like
sitting there on big screen TVs watching
this they want to make men more
sensitive like so that they can be like
you know there's been a lot of rape in
the military male on female especially
with women soldiers now so maybe they're
trying to teach men what it's like to be
a woman you can't that's exactly what
they say yeah that's what they said but
walk on my learning shoes so I'm just
telling you what I mean at the end say
fake news I was told this by real people
well they're certainly wearing high
heels that happened that was a big thing
uh five years ago I want to fact check
it's interesting how we went from Aliens
again right back into this this is weird
so let's leave this and just say it's
fiction
no one's wearing high heels that was a
joke no but it's almost inescapable like
you you you we're gonna do super chats
you said no no let's talk about the
Israeli space security guy let's go back
there and go right back let's go back to
him what do you make of the former head
of the Israeli Space Program which they
have one folks saying was it Global
International Galactic Federation
Galactic Federation what you've been a
joke about what's not coming out so I
can't remember exactly what we were
talking about but we're talking about I
think like war and international
interests and I said Joe the Galactic
Federation will not allow us to enter
until we're unified by one governing
Authority and then Joe immediately went
I don't think there's a Galactic
Federation and a lot of people commented
that it was funny like a really funny
response because I wasn't being serious
and Joe gave me a really serious answer
and then we get this guy saying this
is it possible this job this guy's just
an old crackpot and he's just or he
could be trolling yeah exactly let me
give you my answer in a moment but let
me kiss some Temple ass right now and
some Michael Mouse Dr menace please
don't Dr Menace no no seriously here's
the deal why is he putting on high heels
what's wrong with that because I love
this country and I'm a patriot
no no people ask why do you like shampoo
well hey that's a good question hey I
come home my wife's watching while
eating dinner and I've been watching him
for 10 years but when he people say why
is he being argument over you that's
what he does when you have the CEO of
Twitter on and the head lawyer it was
like Perry Mason but real I mean I am
kissing ass right now because I didn't
see it was a lot of people this is like
10 million views look at this and I was
so being shut down then almost bankrupt
no one's standing up for me and you
boosted me so much in my own personal
when you cut them to Ribbons in that
interview
no seriously and that's why I love you
because so I get why you interrogate me
it's your nature that's good to
interrogate reality but you destroyed
the head of Twitter you destroyed their
lawyer
and it wasn't just that like they suck
because they did suck and do what they
were talking about you were like like a
lawyer doing it like a top lawyer that
was beautiful that's why I appreciate
you doing that because I know it wasn't
about defending me it was about
defending reality right or what was the
moment you're in there for hours
destroying I watched the whole thing
like three times and I watched the
eclipse like 10 times yeah but you know
you know the thing is like
it's funny how during Occupy Wall Street
I can get praise from all these leftists
for defending reality and then I was you
know I got a lot of heavy criticism from
the right not so much they didn't care
about me all that much during occupy but
you know they were certainly trolling in
in the live streams and now we're at
this point where after watching you know
after say like the The Joe Rogan Jack
Dorsey Vijay got a thing the right uh or
whatever you want to call it is saying
wow Timmy did a great job and the left
is like Tim Poole is all bad or you know
he's right wing or whatever but now that
we're moving in its other space with you
know Trump in the election now it's
starting to shift a little bit now I'm
actually getting praise from leftists
there was this this funny meme about who
would you stay in a room with 24 hours
with and all these leftists are like
dimple's actually not that bad of a guy
he's kind of annoying but I could skate
with him or something and now I actually
have people over at the donald.wind
saying I'm like a bald [ __ ] and a loser
who won't accept it so it I I mention
this every time it goes back and forth
for me like a song like Trump's starting
to lose like like this Texas defeat's a
big deal I'm not gonna lie to people
they're gonna they're already mad at me
like why are you saying Trump's in
trouble why have he sold Trump out I'm
not I'm not gonna lie I really I wrote
that song about the cycle of life and
revolutions
Michael you've discovered the true
nature of the universe you don't need to
be sarcastic I'm talking truth to you
and you said so that's great it's got a
smart me looking no no but seriously so
I'm telling you I made a video about how
it goes yeah let's go back to the moment
with the Twitter CEO all right let's go
back you literally that's like some of
the most powerful Perry Mason stuff ever
but it's not a movie it's real I didn't
plan anything do they realize they were
destroyed at the end of that but it
doesn't matter yeah Jack Jack was you
know you know after it does matter a lot
Tim after after listen after that show
you listen Jack came up to me I was like
Mike Tyson in like 1988 yeah listen
versus Estelle Getty after that episode
as we're leaving Jack Dorsey came to me
and he very gently whispered sweet
nothings into my ears and I felt a warm
feeling he says we're gonna make it all
better we're gonna create paths to
Redemption we're gonna allow people a
second chance don't worry everything you
said you're so right and I said ah Jack
you mean it and he was like I mean it
and I was like and it's been two years I
don't want to tell any stories is that
ship of sales but someone we know that
was in the room at that time said the
same thing to me goes I talked to Jack
there's a path to Redemption and and I
really think that Tim got through to him
no and and yeah Joe told me that
seriousness though maybe you did get
through to him at that moment and then
he goes back to his board and they're
like oh cool story yeah he was like
three percent of the company he's not
he's he's a figurehead he's not exactly
I was there Joe Rogan called me and I'm
gonna give it a seat Joe didn't say it
was a secret because man Tim Poole
knocked you out of the park and I'm like
yeah I saw it incredible and he's like
uh yeah you know I think they're really
gonna get a pass what do you say pass
Redemption a pastor Redemption and I got
really jealous oh yeah
don't pull me but dorsey's gonna is what
you just said and it was nothing
happened Jack which then picked pissed
Joe off you know I think Jack is checked
out he's been checked out for a long
time he left Twitter a long time ago he
was fired I think they brought him back
as kind of uh but you founded it so
you're the face titular head you know I
think that's it I was told by somebody
Jack likes you he's trying to fix Free
Speech leave him alone and then I from
him in DC and they banned me that day
and later I confirmed that was real
somebody showed me text messages with
him saying that you have the documents I
was shown documents from two years ago
by somebody else and then magically this
other person showed me text messages
with him saying I like Alex Jones but I
don't control my own company
I'm not just saying this right now to
act powerful this is in all fairness
it's not a surprise that a CEO doesn't
have this unilateral power company like
that he was he was especially a publicly
traded he was preaching blockchain
social media that can't ever be deleted
which is also kind of a bad thing you
know you want to be able to remove posts
you want to be permanent but you want to
know it actually has the the Providence
but I get what you're saying but yeah so
could you go on blockchain under a a a
known to plume if you could own if you
can own blockchain under a Alias so they
could be safer there's there's a there's
there's a lot to try and
figure out
um but imagine I was told by Joe Rogan
hey Jack dorsey's gonna fix it he's
really upset Tim Paul did a great job
and then later I'm like that's BS I know
people that other people confirm that to
me that he had basically actually is
more of a Libertarian is upset about
what's happening and I I thought that
was a patronization at the time but I
think I don't believe it she thinks BS
again yeah so I think if Jack Dorsey
actually cared he'd stand up and and and
and say something at the very least no I
agree I'm not lionizing him I'm just
saying is there any truth to it
the reason so so Jacka said to me even
since then in like you know DMS things
about we're gonna fix it we're trying
we're working on it and the reason I
don't believe him is that when something
happens like they Joe Rogan told me he
said well Jack's working on your path to
Redemption two years ago yes BS if if
Jack Dorsey he could have if he has no
power in the company he could at least
issue a statement saying I firmly reject
the suspension of this individual we
must restore Free Speech rights he
doesn't
he just says you know we're trying very
hard and then he does these these how
many Senate hearings have we had now
where he says the exact same things
seven and they're Lies over and over
again we've got the leaders
we've got the project Veritas has gotten
more than enough more than enough
information from employees at Twitter so
what is his problem
I think uh he doesn't care he doesn't
own the company his job is to just
Advocate on behalf of Twitter and so you
know what I'd be willing to bet I'd be
willing to bet before he went to the
Senate he went to you know Vijay and
said oh what do you want me to say she's
like say these things okay that's it it
does sound like I'll say that with you
when you debated her and him you are
smart but you did a better job than I
would have done I'm being honest but
they were like mental retards I mean I
mean I got kicked off of Twitter for his
Network you know they were yeah that's
bannable I know you could you could
euthanize somebody with you you can kill
babies you can have uyghur death camps
in your Apple but if you use a term they
say you can't your band fine I apologize
the point is
Chris says you I mean people listening
like a lot of times like in my mentions
someone will use that word against
somebody else and I want to give them
the warning no no I agree with that word
so anyone Banning their supports weaker
death camps run by Apple because
remember I don't run any Champs I don't
run death camps in China I don't know
one slave so you say that I use a word
like that I'm bad you are ignoring all
the real crimes and using that attack on
me to shut down what I've said to
support weaker death camps run by Apple
in China I'm just giving advice to
people on Twitter I will agree no Alex
that they looked slow and confused if
you wanted to use a different word yeah
I'm not kissing his ass it was like a
sloth talking to the flash it was like
they had their pants caught down and
didn't know the turtles The Flash has an
arch enemy called the turtle who was his
first arch enemy and he's very slow
really yes that's awesome
number four go back to what you're
saying um when you you were talking to
them specifically about the way they
were saying shout out to each gender
someone and then can you explain that
that confusion and so Jack said you know
we have rules and we follow the rules
and we we apply the rules fairly and I
said your rules are biased and he said
no no they're not and I said yes they
are Twitter has a misgendering policy
it's a rule that only fits the ideology
of the left and is contradictory to the
ideology of the right therefore you've
created a rule that only benefits the
left I'd explain it to them they didn't
understand the concept or they did and
they just don't care because it's not
that I hate a dude that wants to be a
woman or a woman should be a man I don't
care the idea that no even Bill Nye the
Science Guy went back to his 1980s
cartoon that's actually not that's not
true
so there's a meme going around of Bill
Nye talking about jeans it's fake
okay I've seen the video
of them going back and re-editing the
old 1980 show where they there's a
there's a video where he talks about uh
your like gender and stuff but there's a
fake meme where there's a no that's a
video listen let's just say this the
left is saying that chromosomes don't
determine sex they are absolutely yeah
so uh so that's going on and all I'm
saying is I don't care if a dude dresses
like a woman I don't care if a guy is a
woman you're yelling about a dude
dressing like women yeah exactly who was
that the guy's in the high school you're
being forced to do it exactly they're
forced it's what I'm saying is I don't
care if you want to do it just don't
force us to do it fair
does that make sense because I and like
I'm like capitulating I don't care I'm a
Libertarian what I'm getting is did you
vote for Joe Jorgensen or Trump
who
that was the perfect answer thank you
beautiful absolutely beautiful regarding
these past redemptions you can go to
prison and then get out of prison that
was actually like a violent cry for
horrible yeah and I question big events
they took out of context and I'm banned
yeah like how long have you been banned
now they said it's a lifetime it's got
to be a limit that's something actually
brought up on the show I said that you
know someone makes a mistake you give
them a life sentence you can commit
murder in the United States I don't get
told Jim I love your show because I mean
we've been in fights about stuff but
when you explained on air I don't even
say the name of it I barely talked about
a mass shooting and the internet didn't
believe it happened I covered like 10
times they said Jones's identity is
denying the shooting happened and like
six years ago I said no I thought it
happened leave me alone and then Megyn
Kelly twisted and got me like well why
did you question so they can then sue me
and you got it straight you're like
Jones has repudiated this he said he was
wrong and then these people continue to
milk this and bring this up over and
over again when it's not who I am it's
like it's like they take one thing out
of context and they it's like it's like
Groundhog Day it's over and over and
then imagine they're on the news going
he's harassing children he won't leave
us alone help us Jones is attacking us
and I'm like no I'm not a no no and then
they won't stop and it's like you're
trapped in a bad song
that's it it's like a song but it's a
bad one we need to go to super chats
yeah
let's hear for the plebs The
Intergalactic Fleet oh we will I will
tell you the big alien cigaretto I want
to go to you want to you on the show
what's the big alien secret how long do
we have oh yes I mean I don't know but
yeah I will say I think we've tried like
17 times to talk about it and it just
every single time goes back to the exact
same subject so let's cover the
subscription the super let's talk to the
fans let me tell you we gotta talk to
the fans we gotta talk to the fans let
me tell the story what's the story
okay so I'm not enamored by astronauts I
think they're cool test pilots and
they've done amazing things that the
space program is real a lot of it's
secret a lot of this goes on so I knew
Charlie Sheen back before he went crazy
again I knew him back when he was with
uh maybe he just had covet he never had
AIDS yeah exactly but I knew back when
who's who's his wife he married that was
in the Starship Troopers oh Denise
Richards Denise Richards yeah so I knew
him back like imagine being a Charlie
Sheen's house like 2005 and like there's
a Chef cooking dinner and Denise
Richards was there and you're having
dinner with thanks Richard it was fun he
was a big listener his dad was The
Listener his brother Emilio Estevez was
a listener yeah they're really a
Martin she's really you know SFS Martin
the best of us so is that who you bought
the ranch from no I didn't buy a ranch
for them but I'm not name dropping this
is a true story it could be both how to
even tell the story what was I getting
into aliens about Charlie astronauts
astronauts
so
2005 20067 I'd be out there to be on a
TV show or something I go stay at
Charlie Sheen's house then he gets
divorced it's a little more wild stuff
goes a little bit crazy I knew him for
like 10 years good said they're probably
50 times he beats in like a private wide
body jet to pick me up and fly me out
there so it sort of some a few other
people but I went out there and I'm
sitting there and
he goes hey Buzz Aldrin I'm good friends
with Buzz Aldrin you should come on your
show so Buzz Aldrin calls up comes on my
show like a week later then we go to
dinner with Buzz Alder and Buzz Aldrin
is like look we've got major bases on
the moon there's there's a big
equatorial water base and at the
northern South Pole and you know we got
the base and there's an alien base you
know at Mars they're giving it to us and
there's a chore on the moon or whatever
the name of the moon is what's the
single Moon of Mars well that's Focus
it's Pluto I'm sorry sorry whatever it
is he goes we've got this transmitter
base it's we've got the we've got this
Obelisk we communicate with them with
and I'm like let's go on my show and do
that he comes on it became national news
he's like there's an obelisk on the Mars
is one Moon we're in communication with
aliens bus Aldrin said this is Buzz
Aldrin on my show you look this up I
swear to God I believe everything else
you've said we've looked up has been
fast so
so he comes on and about a year later
I'm at Charlie Sheen's house by then
he's partying how is this real he's
partying and he goes let's go to a
steakhouse with Buzz Aldrin so Buzz
Aldrin I'm sitting there eating steak
and L.A Buzz Alder look swimming their
eyes he goes Alex
the Egyptians are run by aliens we have
the base on Mars and we've got an
Intergalactic agreement with them and he
goes but don't worry the Indians in one
year will plant will will land 80 will
land a spacecraft that will crash one on
the moon to find the water and that's
the symbol of The Intergalactic
agreement I'm like okay I'm thinking
he's crazy a year later the Indians
crashed it onto the moon and found the
water so here's some of the time ever
come on again he goes that's some of the
top comments in the video say came here
from the recent Joe Rogan good to hear
Buzz really talked about all this stuff
right except that Jones account is quite
a bit different from the general tenor
of aldrin's remarks Aldrin never said
that aliens built anything
I just told you the rest of the story I
was just reading I talked to him on the
phone and I met with him and he could
call Buzz Aldrin he'll tell you it's
possible that they told him it was
aliens to throw him off and that they
the government built like a listening
post on Mars's Moon yeah no I don't know
he's like we've got an obelisk like 2001
on the moon and and all this stuff I'm
not saying it's real back a second Tim
dude I mean I've hung out with us let's
go back in the video I mean Alex are you
like me when you look at yourself with
like a baby face you're like oh my god
look how old we've gotten
does that creep you out too I mean he's
pretty old here too how old are you Alex
that's not that harmless well this is a
re-upload yeah
that's right yeah eleven thousand with
like deep space TV priorities Bob Lazar
gets a lot of crap for saying that
there's aliens I think they threw him
off off the trail by dude I don't even
I'm
Indians are gonna claim they find the
water they're about to crash a probe in
we already found it over there we've got
a base on the moon and I'm sitting there
in like an L.A and dinner with Charlie
Sheen and them I'm like I've reached the
Twilight Zone and then a year plus later
I'm in an airport and I look at the look
at USA Today and it says
they crash a probe in and make water
eject up type in India crashes crashes
Probe on moon to find water
and they said I went on air and said
Buzz Aldrin says they're gonna crash it
without water and they did
I'm on record saying it before it
happened yeah excellent oh my gosh I'm
just telling you man this is dude I mean
I had Buzz Aldrin on the show a couple
times oh
do you find anything about the probe
smashing on the moon I bet there's one I
mean there's a bunch of shocked if there
wasn't yeah
Indian space agency
crashes Probe on moon to find water dude
I got a feeling on Mars there's so much
water under that iron yeah November 2008
India made the moon impact Probe on
board you know Orbiter crash look
confirmed the presence of water Etc
whether or not there's aliens it could
be missing that was kind of good I've
been doing the super chats super chats
time super chats at band.video okay so
first awards.com
a good portion of the super chats are I
would just call them inappropriate oh
some of them are calls for Action
actually unappropriate ones no those are
the ones I can't read
um let me see
uh AJ Birch says Alex may be the only
man on the planet whose feet I'd smell
read the rest keep it keep it staxxa or
whatever your shirt says Texas just so
you know I was looking at that Super
Chat you gotta start one more over we
got way too many super jets
let's see
Dylan Keller says I'm so sorry I missed
the start of the show if you haven't
already please discuss the Clockwork
elves and extra dimensional uh mantises
with controversial diets I want to
re-ask Tim's question how can DMT allow
us to see around a spatial Corner that
we normally can yeah we're going to talk
about this for half an hour now good
good ways
100 bucks
I've talked to people that work for the
Pentagon we know we talked about this
earlier this guy's gonna use the rewind
no but they've gone and not just
depending on no he said I missed it in
the shows
did Ayahuasca events in Peru and then
you know Belize or whatever where 50
people see the same hallucinations yes
the grandmother
so they see the same hallucination
meaning it's not hallucination there
it's another dimension this is big okay
you don't go to a planet to see aliens
man you it's like the veil's right there
waffles Sensai Sensei says watching
Alex's face shift when Tim explained
what was happening on December 14th was
one of the better 1.4 seconds on the
internet
yep The Awakening I don't get it what
happened
something so when I told you about the
the meteor the comet the meteor showers
the comet and the solar eclipse
happening on December 14th and the
electors are chosen and then the 21st is
the it's it's this it's called the super
conjunction this 800 cycle when Jupiter
and Saturn align and they become one
bright big light in the sky the
Christmas star the Christmas star yeah
it's going to be something
murder yourself all right all right
the coconut cabbie says Tim pool is pure
gangster for hosting these two against
Alex Jones you and your products Rule
now let's just say it in a world of
weenies
you know Tim is King Tim is doing a good
job until I get banned whatever
banned for this why
oh they'll find an excuse whatever
poking the bear yeah PM says this is the
dawning of the age of Aquarius I think
what you meant to say this is the
dawning of the age of Aquarius I'm
pretty sure this is significant for the
Times indeed
I was you ever see you guys ever watch
zeitgeist
yeah it's his bread butter no I was in
the first sight guys and then that that
he had a fake name it was like John Paul
or Peter Joseph or what was it um Paul
Joseph Peter Peter Joseph Peter Joseph
Peter Joseph no the U.N what's the New
York Times question he's like we'll live
in plastic cities and camps and
computers concentric circles will owe
nothing and the computers will tell us
what to do and he goes and Alex if you
don't agree you're going to a camp for
education and later he went I didn't say
that we had the video he's on my show
going you will go to a re-education camp
but it's okay so it's it's okay just
telling someone it's okay doesn't make
it okay I'm talking to you right now
this is for this one's for Ian John
Hutto says 99.99 of all matter is in
plasma State look up plasma University
that's what I'm talking about
interesting possible but not likely
Electro lasers man we're vaporizing
matter and then recombobulating it okay
okay get over here here you go right
here come on we're actually I'm on the
show sublimating matter Luke was
supposed to come on the show I think
he's chilling's lap All Right Here Comes
Here Comes Luke no I mean me and vladder
a lot of people don't know this but Luke
is actually the illegitimate son of
Vladimir Putin why why am I getting
notifications that I'm Alex Jones's uh
illegitimate son yeah and you're my
mother I'm here called a joke
I thought I was the genetically uh
altered weaponized version of you and
Putin making a love child no you know I
think it was I think I think uh a couple
decades ago the US government
stole the genetic material from Putin
and Jones and tried to create a super
being of of governmental Authority but
also who can see through the veil and
they created Luke and it's true
you guys are waiting for me to say
something yeah yeah what do you make
let's go back to this
look I think Trump's better than Biden I
was Trump had won but this Texas defeat
I'm not going to a lot of listeners this
is this is this is this is a major goal
what the GOP chairman just said he's
hinting at uh pretty much going away
from the union and we actually this is
when you had me on the first time I was
like Hey Big developments what's
happening tell us yeah well Alan West
came out with a statement and his
statement essentially is hinting at the
I don't think that's the chairman of the
Texas party hinting you have to quote
you want to read the quote I'm going to
read the quote here
I was going to jump in but I didn't want
to you know no take your time with
myself in there and all that but he said
specifically perhaps law abiding States
should bond together and form a union of
states that will abide by the
Constitution this is wow I I don't think
it's a hint I think he's putting it
right on the nose yeah I mean see how
we're so careful because it's a hint
he's like I'm doing this there's no like
yeah major news that of course people
should actually read that again that's a
big deal the chairman of the Republican
party in Texas
from a new Union
yeah
close law-abiding States should bond
together and form a union of states that
will abide by the Constitution and again
remember when you had when you first had
me on this was the idea that I first
said might it might be the better thing
to do than to break up the union and
have certain States go along a lot of
people that's what you said at the start
of the show there was a one guy a long
time ago said this in fact he wrote an
article about his name was Michael
malice thank you
appreciate it crazy what was that what's
a crazy thing to advocate for isn't it
though I mean I don't mean crazy and
wrong I mean like bold and out there the
situation we're in is crazy I I think
what uh there's been an enormous
asymmetry historic in recent twenties
like a song
there's been an enormous asymmetry in
the last 30 years between how the left
and the right gets their ideas which is
someone did a I bet you even know the
number the window between someone having
an idea on Tumblr and it becoming a New
York Times article was like 18 months
and that was happening on the left
whatever loony idea and then it becomes
codified whereas on the right it was
just kind of arguing with the left and
then it's like okay we're gonna throw
out our own like here's another Arc I
wrote let's use the Obamacare law which
said you have to by law own health
insurance or you could pay a fine
mandatory gun ownership you have to own
a gun if you don't want to pay a fine
that resolves the gun rights issue in
one year because right away you will
never be able to undo it just because of
gun population what about uh sees all if
you worried about privilege no agree we
never play their game
I love you so much uh if you worry about
privilege I'm a gorilla murder yourself
cease all University endowments and
distribute that money as reparations
these are the kind of big yeah they'll
never really do that but if you make the
left pay it if you start with that as
your negotiation let them argue here
instead of always trying to catch up
with right exactly I agree change the
subjects or their own the problem is uh
there's a prominent conservative faction
mainstream that does nothing but chase
the left correct that's all they do but
they've no agree why are they always
chasing the left because their job is to
be they're either low status in that
world or no status in this new right
they put a lot of lightweights in there
yeah that think they're gonna get power
out of the system so here's the big
question
do you guys realize that right now as we
speak
this is on a knife's edge like the sick
part of me is they put Biden in who
can't even talk right this is even
better like what happens to the left if
they actually put that crazy lunatic in
well so what's happening now is the
progressives are starting to get
rejected and dejected black lives matter
tweeted out on Election yeah they're
being thrown out by who they are black
lives matter official organization
tweeted we won on you know in the
declarator for Biden and now they're
like it's been 32 days and they've
refused to respond to us in any
meaningful way it's like you got you're
you're marched for months and now this
pig cop won't even take your calls who
would have thought Kyle Harris you know
Top Cop would reject the you know she's
in her Pig Pen you know wallowing in the
mud oink oink so let's predict let's we
can all procrastinate all day and
procrastinate and pro masculate whatever
words those are those are all the words
yeah no no we we can all make up stuff
but bottom line where's America in one
year let's hear it well we got a Super
Chat uh Daniel Maxwell says where does
Alex think the US will be in six months
across tonight
you what procrastinate procrastinate
that's your answer the Super Chat is
weren't what
they asked where does Alex think the U.S
will be in six months you said a year I
said well the super chats is perfect you
know I think it's up to what we do we
need to recognize this is dangerous and
this is crazy so uh I'll be honest I
don't know where we are in six months
what do you think I mean I'll give you a
very easy answer uh which I think No
One's Gonna even argue with there is uh
marijuana laws were one example of this
which is all marijuana is illegal right
all Maryland dispensaries are in
violation of federal laws they're all
committing felonies every day but
there's no organizational will and the
federal government to actually enforce
it so Obama had rates and it gave up
there is going to be wanton Defiance of
these lockdowns and quarantine
procedures either in a state or
Municipal basis and that is going to
increase that's the Catalyst yeah but
exactly why would I please get my punch
line out you've been talking for hours
actually I think you've got 80 of the
air time on this channel I did not go
ahead Alice
that is going to do an enormous service
towards lessening the any semblance of
authority that these people have over
our lives which is a very key step
towards having them lose their ability
hold on
Christian Del Toro says Alex can you
tell Walter and Natalie congratulations
on the birth of their baby yes I
congratulate your baby can I just say
Walter and Natalie congratulations on
the birth of your baby Walter and
Natalie congratulations from a gorilla
yes
now can we get really serious here so I
want I want to answer that six months
question though yeah
uh in line with what you were saying
it's something I've been saying that uh
you know we had Stuart Rhodes and The
Oath Keepers the largest militia in the
country said that people are not going
to respect anything out of Joe Biden's
mouth as legitimate yes I think in six
months it's not just disregard for all
the lockdowns when people start
disregarding general rule of law yeah
because it's so I'll put this let me
rephrase the lockdowns are so extreme
many people are just saying Fu yes
they're gonna start saying Fu to
everything else in in turn I can't help
it I mean I think it's going to be like
if I can say FU to this what else is
kind of irrelevant here's my prediction
Governors to gitmo
let's hope that's I mean that's that's
Civil War it's not Civil War it's the
opposite of civil how about we giving
them the vaccine I guess depending on
how they get there I'm really stupid
what does that means
that's not doing anything right now
let's ask
Whitmer all of them and Cuomo so let's
ask Christina let's ask Luke what do you
think is going to happen in six months I
think right now what we should do is
have all the government officials and
politicians be the first in line to get
the vaccine and then after that I think
everything will no no hold on hold on
wait wait let me let me stop right there
in all seriousness that's actually a
really good idea not for any jokes no no
no I agreement
knock knock listen listen if they are
the leaders who are supposed to be
leaving the charge we cannot allow them
to get sick and be taken out it's been a
nightmare when Trump was sick when Boris
Johnson was sick we need to make sure
they are going to remain safe so they
should be first in line to get the
vaccines I agree so how do we know
they're really taking it because I agree
I want them to take it all first
it's just an idea
but look where will it be in six months
six months there's going to be a lot
more poverty a lot more lockdowns a lot
more problems I don't see this going
away I mean when you look at the whole
covid-19 system that has been put in
place and the great reset exactly
there's too many people benefiting off
of it for it to go away so we have to
understand that this is still going to
be around there's going to be
complications there's going to be
poverty I don't think we're going to
reach the boiling point in six months
but we're going to get very close to it
and we're gonna have to keep a very
close eye on what's going on and
preparing
just one thing uh it's a very blue
pilled concept that is presented as a
given that it has to be a Civil War as
opposed to a peaceful like
Czechoslovakia and all these other
countries it does not have to happen
violently no I don't want violence
either let me explain something the
globalists admit they're using covet
you've been talking you act like I've
been interrupting no that's why Lydia
was making things you are meddling with
a title of forges of Nature and you will
atone
is that clear Mr malice listen I have
super male vitality and when I take this
not only am I Unstoppable I have the
best boners on the planet
infowarstore.com I'm teasing him no
seriously this is it
here come my boners the Davos group The
globalists admit they're using it right
now to grab power and we must say know
the lockdowns and no to the fear I need
these issues
all right
I'm not mean to say I'm not going to say
it
skeet skeet
I'm a gorilla murder yourself all right
Joshua Hurley says I drank all this
protein now I got rid of some protein
Joshua Hurley says Alex what do you know
about the monolith they found in oh gold
uh what about models they found a gold
one in Colombia they've been putting
those up the globalists have to usher in
like the head of Israeli Space Program
said the aliens are here they mean we
are the globalists We Are The Uber
mention We Rule you it's all an
archetype that they're taking over right
now so this is all like the new age they
know we're Awakening so they want to
confuse us have us fight with each other
to buy in the fact that they're in
control they're aliens well they're not
they're not in charge we're in charge
yeah I kind of what Lynch says oh dear
it's been nice Watching You on YouTube
Tim you are truly going out with a bang
so I'll tell you what's going to happen
uh I'm a gorilla they'll issue a
guideline strike and then I can't upload
on YouTube personally Mike my companies
can't for one week and I think it means
we can't do a live stream on the show
for an extended period of time if
they'll do that for this yes
tonight we didn't do anything bad no no
I'm not kidding check it out compare
really absolutely I want to talk about
this super chat from earlier about 99.99
of the universe being plasma if you
could do me the favor and look up a
plasmoid uh on Wikipedia what is dark
matter pull up the picture of a plasmoid
real quick and you're gonna crap
yourself what does it look like it looks
like a creature like an electromagnetic
so we're about to be a Russian for a
plasma look at this plasmoid now this is
what happens when an electromagnetic
field is activated it looks like a
jellyfish floating through these no it's
it's a it's a figure eight it's infinity
and you see where we are it's in the
upper left there the plasmoid exists
where our stomach would be if that was
one of us laying on our side
this is what's created when elect when a
magnetic field is met that's where the
poopiest dude I think that magnet
magnetic energy is is cognizant or
coherent or something how do they work
this is the man we need dude we're all
in this together
we are brother
I think they should be banned from
YouTube immediately Maverick X says you
all keep this nonsense above it every
Friday and you'll get a Spotify deal as
well
perhaps we'll need one after this might
need one Spotify give me a call
or YouTube's gonna be like no no no no
this one's okay what have we done wrong
we're like I mean
had too much fun let's see
a lot of people are mentioning skoda's
rejections a lot of them are about
skoda's rejections and uh well let's go
over those did you give to give to Rogan
a rifle I did but you didn't give me one
someone said did Joe did Alex bring you
a rifle like he gave to Joe I don't
think I don't think you can Tim I will
give you an eight thousand dollar
300 Win Mag Precision sniper rival the
best Special Forces got like this guy
went about a year ago well let's uh
let's figure out the paperwork this is
the best gun you can buy I can shoot at
600 yards Bullseye six round mag oh wow
boom boom boom it's laser beam power my
favorite ghost I gave it a joke the
Joe's set up for free speaks but I will
give you if I can get one they're hard
to get a 300 Win Mag semi-automatic
death star weapon
we'll let's fill out the paperwork
sounds good I don't have another one I
gave him my gun oh okay let's see
giacomoose uh Giacomo says Tim I thank
you for having my favorite flat earther
Alex on once again I am and I don't
believe a flat Earth because I am an
Oregonian and we have had Malin voting
for as long as I can remember and Kate
Brown uh I can't read the next part it's
just too small I didn't have 80 million
sent out to dead catch
I love how I'm a flat out they're always
like Joe's thinks it's reptiles that's
David I okay here's there's the Earth's
flat no I didn't here's a very safe
Super Chat Michael malice is an amazing
genius who said that this is from
Maverick X oh I don't know who that is
that's your private account I'm like
looking at a lot of these super chats
I'm like I can't read that I can't read
that definitely can't read that one
oh just read it why can't we read what's
coming in I've already sunk uh the
spiciness level of the show and the
lowered threshold for what we can get
away with we'll see I mean it's like
we they they'll cut the feed you know
what I mean like YouTube is sitting
there waiting and they'll delete the the
stream Midstream they do it all to
people how many dopes are watching us
right now a hundred and six thousand oh
wow that's big keep going more other
questions all right let's see
football stadium I'm so blessed that's
where they have child Predators
infowars.com CERN and the Hadron
Collider well here's the deal
this is not BS I remember reading this
20 years ago I didn't believe it so I
went and looked it up their main
mathematicians believe that if you run
enough of these equations in enough
accelerated attacks in these cyclotrons
is what this hadron super collider is
really a cyclotron they were going to
build one in Texas at Waxahachie they
never finished it so they built one even
bigger in Switzerland and in France the
hatred collider and they accelerate
these electrons the different particles
at above light speeds and slam them into
things and so they're able to open up
Gates do this and they admit in the
equations look this up
it could create a strange look remember
the first remake like six seven years
ago Star Trek where he releases that
little drop into the planet implodes it
yeah that's a strange one it's a black
hole and the equation Say it'll create a
strange alert or a black hole routinely
and these guys are in such a cult they
are doing tests they could destroy the
planet and they're very big into
symbology and the Occult especially
through their Opening Ceremonies if you
really want to get freaked they got
Shiva exactly look at the opening
ceremonies of the Highline Creator and
be prepared to be freaked out really
they're in Black robes yes
it's crazy yeah forget Bohemian Grove
exactly look we should go to Europe and
cover the next thing I'll be there let's
go
Connor Connor Murphy Alex and Michael
how long before you see the people left
and the right turn on the police
here's my problem I'll tell you I'm uh
listen listen okay
I know I'm cutting in because you know
come on do you guys see the second
autonomous Zone in Portland the Red
House autonomous Zone yeah
so I completely disagree with antifa
expanding their borders outside and
surrounding other homes and taking over
these streets but I'll tell you this
right now I'm not going to give any
sympathy or respect to Cops who are
evicting people from their homes at a
time when the government took away their
ability to make money and so they can't
pay their bills that's what I was going
to say I was driving or I meant to make
the point you can't say you're
non-essential and then bankrupt somebody
to be evicted and then take them out of
their house exactly you can't that's
what they're saying in New York like my
bar can't stay open I'm going bankrupt
yes and then the cops are the ones who
are coming and break violating the
Constitution I call them oath Breakers
in like in New York we have the right to
peaceably assemble to live our lives
pursue happiness the 14th Amendment and
the cops come and say we don't care just
give us money I want to be clear you
you've been following me for a long time
I followed you I used to be Mr anti cop
that's me and well yeah but I don't like
arbitrary Authority I don't like thugs
the average cop isn't that but the
system's corrupt the average cup is most
certainly that okay fine all I'm saying
is blaming the average cop
makes us blame the cop and said the
political system give me a [ __ ] break
if you if a German Shepherd can do your
job maybe we're using the word hero a
little bit Loosely every single law
passed by these Governors and Senators
is a love letter to Santa without these
men and women in badges willing to
enforce I'm not gonna get talked over
here I'm not disagreeing with you the
cops aren't battling
is exactly the goal get rid of these
damn cops and I'm gonna make my point
every single one of these laws and
lockdowns in quarantine they're not laws
every decrees they're not lies yeah
they're Marshall I'm going to start from
the beginning until I get my point out
all right right but if you say they're
lost I'm saying if people stop blaming
the cops and blaming the laws we'll
change the goddamn laws I don't care
what you're saying there's no law and
what I'm saying is the regulations
they're not that either
it's edict it's the delete the the only
Michael balance
every single law that is passed by these
Governors and Senators that violate the
constitution our love letters to Santa
without men and women in badges willing
to enforce them on innocent people every
single cop does this knowingly and
consciously all the time every cop is a
criminal criminal without exception many
of them are nice people men they're
smart people they're all criminals who
are on video who pull up and they're
like I'm quitting I won't do this or all
the sheriffs who have said no I don't
have a vote to Redemption like Jack
Dorsey for these people for years they
keep us unsafe in our homes I'm in New
York where's my second amendment rights
I'm only unsafe because of these damn
Michael I get your point you're
absolutely right I'm saying blaming the
average cop though we should change the
law and take the government over yeah we
just got officers just got to vote in
the right people Alex okay okay so let's
blame the cops what do we do first of
all have increased contempt for them by
the citizenry which is starting to
happen second of all realize that they
are the teeth but Soros wants that
because he wants to take the cops over
Jessica saurus wants it doesn't mean
it's automatically wrong
number one the cops are the ones who are
implementing sources Vision aren't they
yeah they are yeah that's my point
so to have privatized police just same
way you don't have a Government monopoly
on Health Care there's makes no sense of
a Government monopoly on security you
want to hear a story in Pennsylvania
they have really great gun rights not
the best but a lot better than other
places New Jersey is called one of the
evil seven where they have basically no
gun rights it's very very difficult
there was a story I was told where a
woman was from Pennsylvania and she
wanted to go to Atlantic City which is
like a 45 minute drive maybe an hour
drive from Philadelphia
so she was just some doofy little Normie
woman didn't really know much and she
made the mistake of Legally owning a
weapon and driving to Atlantic City and
got pulled over being the good citizen
she was she respectfully and politely
told the officer that she was carrying
her weapon and the office said oh thank
you man please step out of your vehicle
and she goes okay she gets out because
she's good puts your hands behind your
back you're under arrest a felony she
got charged with the felony she was
looking at like four years in prison and
the NRA intervened and that's the only
reason she didn't go to prison I know
the story there's a story I remember
when I was growing up in Chicago this
was when I was like 20. a woman from I
think Kentucky or Tennessee had a legal
conceal carry and she had a revolver she
was in her 70s she went to visit Chicago
for the first time to go to the to go to
the uh we caught the Sears Tower it's
the Willis Tower now and as she was
preparing to go in there was a metal
detectors and she informed them she's
like I do have my concealed carry with
me and they said all right this way
ma'am and they walked her and they
cuffed her and they came felony charge
she went to prison four years she went
to prison an old woman and I and I and I
wonder about this I was talking to a guy
at a shop and I said
when a person is clearly from
Philadelphia where it's completely legal
there are Law Abiding Citizen this lady
was apparently like you know the late
40s you know old mom woman wanted to go
to spend the weekend in Atlantic City
and have fun by yourself who is this cop
to be like I'm gonna put you in prison
for this
you know what he could have done he
could said ma'am it's actually illegal
what you're doing but I'm gonna tell you
this I'm going to give you an escort
back to Philadelphia to back please you
know don't bring that back into the
state because no you're right there are
cops implementing tyranny and they're
bad oath I'm saying we need to change
the laws
because here's the deal I used to attack
the TSA all day long until like they
were like listeners like please be nice
to us we're just trying to get paid our
job please change the law I'm just gonna
no you're like garbage and I'm getting
paid for you I need my respect you are
you know what they call them in Britain
the filth and with good reason the cops
yes and the CSA or malice what I listen
it's easy to [ __ ] on the cops you know
why because they are [ __ ] because they
got problems what about who doesn't have
problems I'm gonna tell you it's a
cop-out to blame the cops you expect
screw bed cops you got it there's no law
man there are no good cops okay fine all
the cops are bad yes I think that's I
think but let's let's say this
I'm saying change the law stop copping
out to say it's the cops we have to
change the law the second amendment
guarantees my right to a gun and I do
not have it these laws are a joke and
you know they're a joke but
they're not that makes them Hypocrites
oath Breakers
what percent what how many if you put
your hands on a young person who is
selling drugs and you put them uh to get
arrested and have them be traumatized
you are the enemy of civilized human
beings
I don't think non-violent people should
be in prison and I'm out of worship with
the police and I should be the main guy
attacking the police I'm saying we don't
get reformed that way let's change the
law I don't believe in reform I believe
in abolition well you want to reform
about the police of course
explain I just explained everybody was
basically armed who then get somebody to
go to court once somebody steals your
steals your car or steals your house you
would have privates to us there's no
there's no you've been involved in legal
systems as I have and you know perfectly
well but
and also how expensive they are how much
the average person does not have access
to Legal Services you have to buy a
lawyer which costs more than buying a
surgeon if you had a private system
where there's private adjudication which
we have already it would be a lot easier
things to get resolved quickly and you
would have a lot more access to free
situations and you would have ratings
for these different legal systems
I was going to say the states don't
really follow the laws just like Jeffrey
Epstein just like they don't pay taxes
yeah do you know do you know that the
politicians is there's an old saying I
don't know it's been a long time since
I've been there but the uh the local
politicians in Chicago are allowed to
carry concealed what about um Mayor
Bloomberg oh no all the Democrats get to
go get their hair cut yes and they get
to have armed security
here's the thing if you were a trump
voter which I it's that's your
prerogative if you thought there was any
chance that Hillary Clinton was going to
jail you are so removed from reality I
don't even know seriously they can't
she'll release all the other info well
it's not even that these people never
get consequences when did I mean a
Hillary Clinton to Richard Nixon none of
these people go to jail they never have
consequences you're the you Alex you
talk about this constantly how many
receipts do you have over the years of
these horrible people admitting through
horrible things and nothing ever comes
of it well Epstein finally got a snack
program sure but how many stories died
with him how many victims never got
Justice with that no I agree they got
rid of his ass yeah yeah exactly
well then
it's a very likely yeah very very easy
going very powerful show actually I I
actually uh I think Michael is
completely wrong I think we need to do
the opposite of abolish the police we
need to make everyone a cop and yes
deputize everyone yeah
Mountain Dew he teaches you to hit cops
here's my deal
I get people I'm out of authority and I
want an American Republic limited
government
there's some role with police I'm not
police asking a single position I'm just
saying just blaming the cops becomes a
cop-out you're just talking circles
doesn't mean to cop out there's plenty
of blame to go around when you're
dealing with terrorists I think you know
you know uh I think when you when you
blame the cops it's a surface level uh
assessment so it's not uh here's what
I'm saying you're not wrong but like the
deep-seated issues that have resulted in
this problem this problem won't be
solved by just saying something
something police I agree that if you
cure covid you're not curing cancer I'm
just saying they are cancer what I'm
saying what I'm saying is that there is
a a problem in this country where people
walk into the voting booth and say D or
R and they ignore who they're voting for
these people then get in and say what's
the easiest path I don't care about this
if voting changed anything they'd make
it illegal
all right in closing let's talk about
secret space program well we only have a
couple more minutes I think yeah we're
done then
fun career for me and uh thanks to
YouTube I was I reached a million subs
and said okay I'm done I'll just have
the craziest show possible and then the
first time they gave me a warning and
this is one thing oh seriousness one of
the best things about 2020 is how so
many more conservatives are being
skeptical about police because there's
so many videos no no I I agree they're
concerned with the lockdowns people are
like all right they're not Angels
they're flawed and that's all I ask I'm
a gorilla
murder yourself it's been nice knowing
you everybody what I'm getting at is
you're right I'm just saying the police
or the low level of the government
they're the level yeah so if you have a
problem with government you should
change the laws blaming police is a
cop-out it's so fashionable to attack
police and police have problems what's
wrong with being fashionable we can't
all be sitting in Texas shirts
all I'm saying is
is that is that is that no one should
visit banned dot video
people say where's Alex Jones I'm an
info where's doctor you're saying they
should instead go to Governors to
gitmo.com and get their free shirt is
that a real website
oh man this is CNN
provided by Tim pool that's right so
I'll just put it this way look when uh
when we did the first show it was it was
massive and then uh they took the show
down and I immediately was like you guys
got to come back because and you were
Fair because I get I was talking so fast
well I think I was like I said something
I didn't say I just want to say I love
Bill Gates I love you no I think I think
you you assumed he's had the same thing
I I thought he said yeah yeah so so you
know I guess that was but they YouTube
clarified it didn't matter what we
thought even the joke itself was
bannable wow yeah so that's BS it's
complete BS uh what was the show for
them yeah I'm not gonna repeat it
oh yeah because we're gonna advance
so uh Michael do you have a social media
you want to tell people about uh
twitter.com Michael malice and
malice.locals.com ban that video and
it'll be uh this is the last big shout
out so um while you can you can follow
me on Twitter well you can follow me on
Twitter Instagram and Paul I'm not going
anywhere on those platforms at timcast
but for my other YouTube channels
youtube.com timcast and youtube.com
timcast news but uh seriously the worst
case scenario they told me that I'll get
a seven week suspension and this show
gets shut down for a week or seven days
uh seven days okay you got a lot of
Courage people like oh Champions but let
me leave a lot of Courage infowars.com
seven uh if if this one gets put on
their radar and they strike uh for seven
days I can't upload anything and it's
very likely that we can't do this show
for an extended period of time like
until there's some kind of like
doing that so you do a good show it's
like really reasonable you know I don't
know whatever it is what it is it was
funny because I a lot of people were
like accusing me of cop of copping out
because the show got pulled I'm like I
didn't pull the show now and YouTube did
I saw that conspiracy I'm not joking I
saw that you tried to get me back like a
week later I was already no not even I
said come back the next Monday weekend
shows there was a conspiracy theory that
said you called YouTube and asked them
to pull it so you'd have more
controversy because because you make
your videos unlisted so that's what
they're getting that from oh
well they're not on nothing anymore
they're all fine
I was here on the weekend you're like
can you come back tomorrow I'm like
sorry I don't have a babysitter yeah
that's right you'll be like on Sunday or
Monday I I said the next show is Monday
can you guys come back and you said
maybe I said Michael and Michael's like
I can do well actually you were like
it's tough and then you were like I got
a family and I was like I get it and
then this was the soonest we could make
it happen my parents were keeping the
children yeah it's it's crazy that no
that was not made up by Tim they banned
it they abandoned it all because they
took something out of context we can't
say
and then they changed it later when they
got called out for it so I can't I can't
specify because they moved to another
infraction I mean no it was the same one
same one but they just changed the rules
yeah
so oh I didn't know that kind of like
how the cops you know enforce it so uh
Ian
well while Luke is already sitting there
you want to shout out here well thank
you Tim for your courage and thank you
for letting me live in your parking lot
thank you appreciate that and uh my
YouTube channel is we are change but we
are changing it's you know you're just
here because once they banned me and I'm
broke I'm gonna become much enough
you'll be like well that's right look
man who's there with Max Kaiser in at
the Bilderberg meeting oh my God and I
told them I told them too I was like Max
you're crazy leave me alone I gotta
fight the globalism so wait a minute I
didn't know this I forgot you were there
yeah was he not giving us a million
years of Bitcoin yes I was like Buck off
Max leave me alone I'm sick and tired
your little nerd money I'm here to make
teddy bears so let's end this with this
tell the story I forgot we were what was
that thing of north of London what's
that town called uh what was it Del Ford
no Bedford I forgot but but we shut down
the town where we had like 5 000 people
minimum minimum like there's people that
couldn't attend our rally because it was
there was too many people the problem
Minister came in and Bilderberg got
exposed yep yep remember back then
there's no world government there's no
secret Banker meeting yeah like they
would deny the major media was telling
you there was no Bilderberg it never
existed
I remember this when it was like the
crazy conspiracy and then the funny
thing happened there was this journalist
who was always on an occupy and the
guardian made him go cover it and he was
like what is this and then all of a
sudden it was like this is a real thing
same thing Charlie Skelton amazing
writer does amazing he did a good job
with the Deep States Trump's crazy
Trump's crazy you're paranoid there's no
deep State then the next year thank gosh
the Deep state is keeping us yeah
over a few of those cards well so so
let's let Luke
so yeah my YouTube channel we are change
Ian come over here
that we didn't talk about uh space
aliens we did
it they don't come in saucers it's
interdimensional they're in the other
dimensions it's all ethereal it's inside
you no it's behind the mirror and
outside you okay thanks everyone uh
follow me to in Crossland and of course
you can follow at Sour Patch Lids who's
been pushing the buttons the whole time
I've been pushing buttons tonight
and uh I guess uh we'll find out if I
will see you in the next week or so you
may go to The Phantom Zone for what
you've done all right video
well everybody thanks for hanging out
and uh again I'll uh well if I'm
uploading tomorrow I will and if not
I'll be taking a great vacation you see
that's the best part of this is I get to
take a week off I get to go fishing I
get to go kayaking and all that stuff
and then I can be like it's not my fault
I can't work Jones and Michael
Missouri is beautiful
there's a thousand lakes or something
isn't it is that Missouri no that's
Minnesota that's Minnesota yeah I said
that last time didn't I yeah I think so
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
see you all when we're back bye-bye bye
guys